bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat mercredi le Parlement a
donné son feu vert à la nomination de
trois femmes au Conseil constitutionnel
mais avant cela deux d'entre elles ont
été auditionnées par la commission des
lois de chaque assemblée les sénateurs
ont donc entendu Nicole Boubé rectrice
académie mais aussi élu socialiste c'est
la candidate qui avait été proposée par
Jean-Pierre belle pour siéger au Conseil
constitutionnel et Nicole maestraci
première présidente de la cour d'appel
de rouan qui avait été quant à elle et
bien proposé par François Hollande je
vous propose donc de suivre tout de
suite leurs auditions bonne matinée à
tous nous allons avoir l'honneur de
procéder successivement aux auditions de
Madame Nicole Boubé à qui je souhaite la
bienvenue venu et de Madame Nicole
maestrachci dont les nominations sont
proposées
respectivement par le président du Sénat
et par le Président de la République
pour exercer les fonctions de membres du
Conseil
constitutionnel en application du 5e
alinéa de l'article 13 de la
Constitution ces nominations ne peuvent
intervenir qu'après l'audition des
candidats devant notre commission
auditions qui doivent être suivies d'un
vote le vote aura lieu tout à l'heure
dans la salle euh de la commission hein
euh la
nomination du candidat proposé par le
Président de la République doit
également être procédé d'une audition
par la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale celle-ci euh est
en cours puisqu'elle a commencé ce matin
à 9h15 à
l'Assemblée les modalités de ces
auditions et du vote on ont été précisé
par la loi organique du 23 juillet 2010
et la loi ordinaire de la même date il
est ainsi prévu que l'audition est
publique et donc ouverte à la presse et
donc télévisée à l'issu des auditions
nous procéderons au vote qui se
déroulera à bulletin secret comme le
prévoit l'article 19 bis de notre
règlement en application de la loi du 23
juillet 2010 il ne peut pas y avoir de
délégation de
vote pour la candidate proposée par le
Président de la République le
dépouillement sera effectué
simultanément à l'Assemblée nationale et
au
Sénat pour la candidate présentée par
Monsieur le Président du Sénat cette
simultanéité ne s'impose pas puisque
vous nêtes vous ne serez entendu que par
le Sénat mais c'est très important
d'être entendu par le Sénat je vous
rappelle enfin que le le président du
Sénat ne pourra
procéder à la nomination de Madame
Boubé que
si il n'y a pas une situation dans
laquelle les votes négatifs
représenterit au moins les 3/5è des
suffrages
exprimés il en serait de même s'agissant
du candidat proposé par le Président de
la République si l'addition des votes
négatifs de chaque
commission c'est pourquoi le
dépouillement est
simultané représenter au moins 3/5e des
suffrages exprimés dans les deux
commissions qui en l'espèce sont
additionné voilà donc après ce ce rappel
un peu austère en ce début de journée
mais
nécessaire je suis heureux de
d'accueillir en votre nom à tous madame
Boubé je vais vous donner la parole pour
un exposé
liminaire
peut-être de d'un quart d'heure
hein environ quoi un quart d'heure dans
lequel vous pourriez nous expliquer si
vous le voulez bien votre
parcours l'idée que vous vous faites de
cette mission de membre du conseil
constittu elle qui est tout à fait
éminente bien sûr et puis peut-être si
vous aviez des idées sur le devenir du
Conseil constitutionnel vous savez que
nous parlons beaucoup ici de ces sujets
il y a même des des propositions de
réforme certains voudraient qu'il y ait
des opinions dissidentes certains
voudraient que l'on change la
composition si jamais vous avez des
idées vous pourrez les exprimer mais
peut-être nos collègues auront l'idée de
vous questionner sur ces différents
points et sur d'autres donc si tout le
monde en est là d'accord je vous donne
la parole madame Nicole
Boubet monsieur le Président je vous
remercie mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs je dois
effectivement au président du Sénat et à
sa proposition l'honneur de me de me
présenter aujourd'hui devant
vous pour me présenter dans un premier
temps et vous entendre ensuite et tenter
de répondre à vos
questions au
fond la ma présentation e été assez
simple si je partageais les idées de
pegy selon lesquelles tout est tout est
joué avant 12 ans je vous aurais alors
parlé assez rapidement je vous rassure
de de ma famille qui est originaire de
laavyon en région
médipyéné une famille d'agriculteurs et
mes grands-parents sont venus à Paris
ils étaient bouia comme on disait à
l'époque
puis cafetier et puis je suis donc né de
ce fait moi-même à Paris j'ai de ma
famille me semble-t-il et notamment mes
cousins agriculteurs chez lesquels j'ai
très très souvent séjourné j'ai acquis
notamment les valeurs du
travail qui sont chez moi je crois
assez assez cardinales y compris dans
les défauts que çaela peut avoir voilà
je ne partage pas cependant les opinions
de pegy donc sur ce point-là je
considère que tout n'est pas joué avant
12 ans je pense plutôt comme hasme queon
ne n'est pas homme on le devient phrase
qui a détourné ou reprise Simone de
beauauvoir donc c'est une au fond une
construction un peu plus lente que
chacun d'entre nous connaît et que j'ai
connu aussi et je crois que si le
président du Sénat m'a fait l'honneur de
cette proposition c'est précisément
parce que je suis peut-être porteuse
d'expériences diverses d'expériences
croisées qui font que je me retrouve
aujourdhu aujourd'hui devant vous je
suis à la fois j'y reviendrai tout à
l'heure professeur de droit et de ce
point de vue-là la nomination la
proposition de nomination au Conseil
constitutionnel est évidemment un enjeu
important pour un universitaire juriste
puisque je considère que c'est quand
même une des institutions assez
cardinales de notre
République je j'ai été au fonctionnaire
en tant que rectrice d'académie j'y
reviendrai également et la gestion d'un
service public est assez particulière
singulière me semble-t-il et forge aussi
des expériences je suis élu territorial
et de ce point de vue-là je crois que la
réalité la quotidienneté de la relation
avec les citoyens est essentielle et
puis euh vous n'aurez pas manqué de
l'observer je suis une femme et de ce
point de vue-là et depuis longtemps je
suis porteuse euh des combats pour
l'égalité pour la parité et il me semble
que c'est aussi un vecteur important
j'ai d'ailleurs dans ce cadre-là mais je
n'y reviendra ait pas eu l'occasion de
présider un comité de suivi pour
l'égalité des chances entre les filles
et les garçons dans les systèmes
éducatifs et puis d'écrire deux ou trois
articles je voudrais revenir si vous m
autorisez sur les trois points majeurs
qui on
scandait la trajectoire que j'ai été
amené à faire je suis d'abord
universitaire et professeur de droit de
ce point de vue-là euh je je suis admin
administrativiste au départ puisque j'ai
fait une thèse sur pouvoirs et relations
hiérarchiques dans l'administration
française c'était la 4e thèse sur ce
sujet du 20e siècle je ne suis pas sûr
de l'avoir épuisé en tout cas j'ai passé
beaucoup de temps à la faire
puisque je n'avais pas eu de bourse ou
de de poste à l'université donc je
travaillais à temps plein j'aileva mes
jeunes enfants et donc j'ai mis je crois
7 ou 8 ans pour faire ma thèse ensuite
c'est allé assez vite puisque j'ai été
nommé maître de conf maîre pardon maître
de conférence à l'Université de parien
puis agrégé dans la foulée en 1992 donc
professeur ensuite à l'université d'evvr
pendant tout ce temps-là j'ai fait ce
que fait un professeur d'université
c'est-à-dire à la fois des travaux de
recherche des colloques des des ouvrages
essentiellement en droit administratif
avec quelques incursions en droit
communautaire et en droit
constitutionnel voilà j'ai
également eu la possibilité pendant ces
années-là assez rapidement d'ailleurs de
dériver vers une maison qui est juste en
face du Sénat c'est-à-dire vers ce qui
s'appelait à l'époque l'Institut
international d'administration publique
où pendant 3 ans j'ai été directrice de
la recherche et euh dans ce cadre- là
c'est aujourd'hui Lena au deux avenu de
l'Observatoire ancienne école coloniale
devenue école de la France d'outrem puis
instittu internationale administration
publique et aujourd'hui Lena et j'ai
passé donc 3 ans euh ce qui m'a permis
de faire de très nombreuses mission
d'expertise ou de formation dans des
pays d'Afrique francophone anglophone
d'Asie et c'est évidemment également
très formateur voilà toujours dans ces
fonctions de professeur
d'université j'ai eu la chance de
diriger la revue françaiseadministration
publique bien sûr qui était lié à à
l'enat et également d'être membre du
comité de rédaction de la revue pouvoir
qui est une revue de Scien politique où
j'ai eu la chance de coordonner des
numéros de d'écrire également
avec d'ailleurs certains enseignants qui
sont aujourd'hui sénateurs voilà euh je
dirais que c'est pour ma fonction de
professeur ce métier de pas ma fonction
d'ailleurs ce métier de professeur de
droit euh je l'exerce toujours et j'ai
toujours voulu l'exercer jusqu'à présent
en tout cas et de manière assez
volontariste et assez obstiné
considérant que alors sauf pendant ma
période où j'étais rectrice considérant
en tout cas par rapport à la vie
politique que les fonctions électives ne
doivent rester que des fonctions par
définition temporaire alors que un
métier c'est quelque chose d'acquis et
même si on doit en changer en tout cas
c'est une base solide et donc j'ai
toujours souhaité jusqu'à présent
exercer ce métier j'ai ensuite été je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure au
fonctionnaires en exerçant les fonctions
de rectrice
d'académie euh je dirais que c'est un
peu les hasards de la vie colorer des
compétences ce que j'avais acquise comme
universitaire et doublé de la volonté du
Premier ministre d'alors de féminiser la
haute fonction publique qui m'a valu la
possibilité d'être nommée rectrice
d'abord à limoge puis ensuite à Toulouse
j'ai donc exercé ses fonctions pendant 8
ans je crois à peu près et si vous
voulez dans ce cadre moi j'ai retenu
peut-être quatre choses importantes euh
d'abord c'est la gestion euh la
direction et la gestion d'un grand
service public pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée l'académie de Toulouse c'est
50000 personnes enseignants
administratifs donc il faut avoir cette
capacité avec d'autres bien sûr avec une
équipe à gérer tout cela c'est aussi un
service public l'éducation qui est
essentielle pour la République je crois
que l'école a institué la République
condoret le disait il fallait former des
citoyens non seulement éclairés non
seulement éclairer mais il disait des
citoyens incommodes et j'aime beaucoup
ce ce terme là en ce qu'il révèle
d'esprit critique donc au fond ce lien
entre la République et l'école est
essentiel l'école a aussi d'une certaine
manière alimenter les sorts du pays
pendant les 30 glorieuses aujourd'hui
l'école est un peu plus en difficulté
elle est
désacralisée
c'est résultats font l'objet de d'études
de contreperformance et il faut donc que
ensemble nous réfléchissions à ce que
doit être l'école pour la République et
je crois que le travail qui est en train
de s'accomplir de ce point de vue-là est
assez
essentiel gestion d'un service public
gestion d'un service public lié à la
République gestion également me
semble-t-il d'un service public qui est
porteur d'enjeux primordiaux pour notre
démocratie je n'irai pas plus loin mais
moi je dirais qu'en tant qu'élu local je
suis infiniment persuadé qu'il n'y a de
développement des territoires que quand
on peut créer de l'innovation et il n'y
a de l'innovation que s'il y a de la
formation et de l'éducation l'éducation
est donc un enjeu capital et donc je
crois qu'il faut considérer que
l'éducation c'est un investissement
d'avenir et ce n'est pas seulement un
coût comme on peut parfois le le
présenter de ce point de vue-là j'avais
remis un rapport à Jacques langang en
2001 euh qui s'intitulait 30
propositions de réforme pour le lycée et
je crois qu'il allait déjà en ce sens
enfin dernier point que j'ai tiré de ces
fonctions de recteur c'est un service
public me semble-t-il l'éducation
nationale qui suppose assurer une
construction partagée des politiques
entre l'État et les collectivités
territoriales et cette construction
partagée on la voit elle est aujourd'hui
à l'œuvre et elle doit me semble-t-il se
finalisé par un nouvel élargissement des
compétences des collectivités
territoriales voilà au fond ce sont ces
questions-l au travers du système
éducatif qui ont donné naissance à mon
engagement à la
fois au côté de l'actuelle ministre dans
le cadre de la refondation de l'école
puisque Vincent payon m'a confié la
présidence d'un des quatre groupes de
travail
de la concertation sur la refondation de
l'école celui qui était consacré à la
réussite scolaire et puis c'est aussi
peut-être ce qui a fondé mon engagement
politique c'est donc le dernier point
sur lequel je je souhaiterais revenir
devant vous puisque je suis élu
territorial alors j'ai toujours eu le
goût de la chose publique ce goûtl m'est
venu assez tôt dès ma première heure de
cours à l'université j'ai à l'époque
rencontré par hasardvid évidemment une
professeure d'histoire du droit
voyez-vous d'histoire du droit public et
j'ai su immédiatement ce que je voudrais
faire plus tard être professeur
d'université je voulais à l'époque
l'être en Histoire du droit je l'ai été
en droit public mais qu'importe ce qui
était né là c'est ce goût de la chose
publique je l'ai
exercé depuis très très longtemps j'ai
été à vrai dire élu pendant des années
d'opposition dans un petit village de la
banlieue parisienne et j'étais à
l'époque une simple militante évidemment
une fois mes fonctions de rectrices
achevées j'ai souhaité euh reprendre cet
engagement et j'ai alors eu la chance
d'être élu euh aussi bien à la ville de
Toulouse qu'à la Communauté Urbaine du
Grand Toulouse et au conseil régional de
midi Pyréné j'ai exercé des fonctions
dans les exécutifs de ces collectivité
territoriale puisque en tant que
première adjointe au maire de Toulouse
j'avais en charge la culture et en tant
que première vice-présidente de la
Région mipyrénée fonction que j'exerce
aujourd'hui je suis en charge de
l'éducation de l'enseignement supérieur
et de la Recherche je retrouve donc là
un lien assez naturel avec ce que j'ai
toujours fait ces cinq dernières années
m'ont permis
euh de prendre conscience euh finalement
de prendre conscience oui qu'il y a un
autre regard sur l'action publique qui
doit être compatible avec le regard de
l' état qui doit se conjuguer il s'agit
d'abord de conduire des politiques
publiques orientées en fonction du choix
des électeur et de ce point de vue-là je
dirais que j'ai été très marqué lorsque
j'étais adjointe à la culture par le
travail que nous avons conduit et qui
est à l'œuvre d'une certaine manière
aujourd'hui dans la réforme des temps
scolaires sur le fait de pouvoir donner
accès à tous les jeunes Toulousains à
une pratique ou à une éducation
culturelle très soutenue euh et cela
faisait partie des orientations
évidemment que nous avions souhaité
prendre je crois aussi que ce qui est
important quand on est élu c'est de
traduire pour tous nos territoires des
décisions dans la région qui est la
mienne j'ai une grande métropole nous
avons une grande métropole Toulouse 1
million et demi d'habitants et puis des
territoires extrêmement ruraux c'est une
région qui est grande comme la Belgique
il faut donc construire des politiques
qui soient au service de cette diversité
des territoires et de ce point de vue-là
je dirais que l'égalité s'exprime un peu
parfois comme pour les individus dans
une forme de compensation républicaine
et puis enfin je crois que ce qui est
important c'est de prendre en compte des
problématiques sociales ou économiques
de manière assez innovante et nous avons
dans notre région j'ai eu l'occasion
avec le président de la région de
construire un schéma régional pour
l'enseignement supérieur et pour
l'action économique et et l'innovation
qui d'une certaine manière anticipe ce
que la loi si vous le si vous le décidez
ainsi la loi sur l'enseignement
supérieur ou la décentralisation votera
peut-être dans dans quelques temps voilà
donc il me semble que ce passage du
service de l'État au service des
collectivités territoriales c'est aussi
celui d'un autre dialogue très concret
avec les citoyens il me semble que c'est
très important je ne vais pas aller
au-delà à ce stade je pense que ces
expériences diverses multiples ont sans
doute été à l'origine du choix et de la
proposition faite par le président du
Sénat je n'ai pas ici parlé des
rencontres des hommes et des femmes que
j'ai rencontré tout au long de ces
étapes et qui sûrement ont eu une
influence décisive sur le trajet que
j'ai eu ce n'est pas je crois ici
l'occasion de le faire mais il me semble
que c'est tout cela qui construit un
individu c'est peut-être la raison de de
la proposition du président du Sénat
voilà monsieur le Président ce que je
voulais dire merci Madame le professeur
Madame le Recteur madame madame la
Présidente euh pour cette recteur oui je
sais je dis Madame le Recteur je sais
pas Madame la Rectrice c'est un sujet
oui on dit alors moi je après avoir
hésité je disais la rectrice au début
j'ai hésité parce que mais après plus du
tout et maintenant je disais la rectrice
mais je ne veux pas engager le débat ici
non c'est une question dont nous parlons
parfois alors mes chers collègues euh je
vais vous donner la parole je sais pas
si vous êtes des citoyens incommodes
comme il a été dit tout à l'heure euh
mais vous êtes des sénateurs alors qui
qui s'inscrit voilà alors j'ai monsieur
Gor monsieur
Géard monsieur Colomba monsieur
mard monsieur
cointa monsieur
Mercier monsieur
Richard Monsieur le Comte j'ai commencé
par regarder de d'un côté hein
mais
bien peut-être on prend toutes les
questions en
suivant pour que vous puissiez faire une
réponse globale à cette première série
de questions il pourra y en avoir
d'autres éventuellement après donc
monsieur Gor
oui merci monsieur le Président d'abord
je crois que je voudrais exprimer le
sentiment qui est celui de cette
commission la satisfaction de voir que
une femme est nommée par le président du
sén au Conseil constitutionnel je crois
que c'est une évolution importante mais
ce ne serait pas faire justice à vos
qualité madame que de s'en tenir à cette
observation quant à l'appréciation de
votre propre candidature je me
permettrai d'y apporter quelques
questions
complémentaires vous nous avez vous avez
évoqué votre parcours professionnel
universitaire à la marge politique qui
est tout à fait respectable et
intéressant vous allez maintenant
occuper des fonctions sein du conseil
constiel qui vont vous amener au
contraire à utiliser plus strictement
encore ces compétences universitaires et
juridiques et c'est sur ces points que
j'aimerais euh vous interroger
rapidement euh plusieurs questions sont
euh régulièrement en débat entre le
Parlement et et le Conseil
constitutionnel lié à l'actualité ou
plus générale j'en retiendrai que deux
ou trois pour ne pas être trop long
monsieur le Président sinon vous m'en
feriez reproche la première question
porte sur la difficulté qu'il y a
souvent à concilier des préoccupations
d'ordre différent qui ont une valeur
constitutionnelle quasi équivalente nous
aurons bientôt un débat sur les
questions qui sont liées à la fin vie
j'aimerais connaître votre sentiment sur
la conciliation possible entre le droit
à la vie qui n'est pas strictement
consacré par notre Constitution mais qui
fait partie de notre ordre juridique et
la liberté individuelle qui donne à
chacun le droit aussi de choisir les
conditions de sa mort autre type de
débat dont vous aurez à vous occuper une
fois au Conseil constitutionnel celui
sur le cumul des mandats il y a
aujourd'hui un débat pour savoir si la
compétence en matière de cumul des
mandats est partagé entre les deux
assemblées ou si elle ne porte que pour
l'Assemblée nationale s'agissant de
l'organis du statut des parlementaires
j'aimerais savoir si vous avez sur ce
point précis un sentiment puis dernière
question peut-être plus simple celle de
savoir si vous estimez que le Conseil
cons tel qu'il fonctionne ces modalités
de nomination les caractéristiques de
ces délibérations les respons qui sont
les siennes sont satisfaisantes au
regard d'une démocratie
avancée merci Monsieur Gor monsieur
Géard merci monsieur le
Président Madame chers
collèguesis vous poser quelques petites
questions tout d'abord quels étaient les
cours que vous
enseignez dans la faculté dans les
facultés dans lequelle vous êtes avez
parcouru vous étiez à Paris vous étiez à
Toulouse parce que il me semble que
votre spécialité c'est plutôt la science
administrative que le droit
constitutionnel et alors en liaison avec
cette première question j'aimerais
savoir quels sont les travaux de
recherche que vous a parce qu'on ne
figure pas vous nous avez donné le titre
de votre thèse très bien mais quels sont
les travaux de recherche que vous avez
mené il est vrai que quand on est
recteur et président de conseil régional
n'a pas tellement le temps de faire des
la recherche très importante mais bon on
aimerait savoir quel est quels sont les
principaux articles que vous avez pu
publier alors le président sur vous a en
vous
présentant mentionner l'idée que vous
pourriez nous présenter votre idée du
Conseil constitutionnel vous l'avez pas
fait peut-être
volontairement pour répondre aux
questions que nous allons poser en fait
vous nous avez fait une présentation
tout à fait magnifique pour présenter un
une candidature aux élections
sénatoriales je ne suis pas convaincu
que c'était la meilleure formule pour ce
pour être candidat au Conseil
constitutionnel mais enfin bon on va on
va voir ça avec la discussion et
qu'est-ce que vous pensez donc là je
vais reprendre un peu ce qu'a dit
Monsieur Gor j' rentrerai pas dans les
détails de telle ou telle loi mais il y
a un certain nombre de projets de
réforme du Conseil constitutionnel
monsieur les a mentionné qui qui circule
depuis de nombreuses années hein il y a
d'abord est-ce que le la présence des
président de la République est est à
maintenir ou pas ensuite deuxième
question qui qui
s'impose on en a parlé ce sont les
opinions dissidentes dans beaucoup de
cours constitutionnelles les membres des
cours constitutionnelles ont le droit
d'émettre des opinions dissidantes la
tradition du Conseil constitutionnel
c'est comme vous le savez l'unanimisme
on se met d'accord avant et et une
personne n'est en désaccord avec la
décision prise ce qui est pas tout à
fait vrai
d'ailleurs ce qui me permettraiit
d'ailleurs d'envisager s'il y avait des
opinions dissidentes les décisions
prises à la à l'unanimité les décisions
prises à la majorité qui n'auraiit pas
valeur identique les unes pouvant créer
précédent les autres pas ensuite il fa
peut-être que vous nous disiez un mot de
ce que vous pensez des QPC des questions
prioritaires de
institutionnalité il y a là également
une innovation tout à fait importante
qui correspond d'ailleurs à la dernière
question de Monsieur Gor dans une
certaine mesure
sur le rôle la place le sens du Conseil
constitutionnel qui s'apparente de plus
en plus comme vous le savez non plus à
ce qu'il était mais à une cour
constitutionnelle il y a plus beaucoup
de différence entre l'un et l'autre et
puis enfin est-ce que vous pourriez nous
dire un mot sur le mode de désignation
des membres du Conseil constitutionnel
merci Monsieur Géard monsieur Colomba
oui madame ma question est un peu dans
le prolongement de celle du du Doyen
Géard pensez-vous que l'action du
Conseil constitutionnel a une dimension
politique et si oui
jusqu'où monsieur Colomba je vous
félicite pour cette remarquable
concision mais la question est difficile
c'est comme les sujets de dissertation
qui ne durent qu'une ligne monsieur mard
oui
madame moi je m'attacherai puisque je
j'aurais aussi posé la même question que
notre collègue Gor et une partie des
questions du du Doyen Géard mais je
m'attacherai donc à votre expérience
d'élu local vous avez on peut on ne peut
que vous en féliciter en être heureux
une carrière fulgurante d'élu local
premier jointe à la mairie de Toulouse
communauté urbaine première
vice-présidente du conseil
régional jusqu'où seriez-vous allé mais
vous me direz le le Conseil
constitutionnel est déjà une une belle
expérience alors j'aurais deux questions
cette carrière politique quand même
assez fulgurante vous la devez à au
scrutin proportionnel et à vos qualités
quel est quelle est votre opinion
par rapport au scrutin par rapport à la
au scrutin proportionnel par rapport au
scrutin uninominal dans l'articulation
de notre vie politique et deuxème
question quel est votre sentiment après
ces 5 années d'expérience sur la
décentralisation et sur le rôle de
l'État par rapport à nos
territoires merci monsieur monsieur
Quinta oui madame j'ai trois petites
questions à vous poser la première
rejoint un peu celle du Doyen Géard
concernant les QPC vous savez que le
Conseil constitutionnel depuis sa
création a beaucoup évolué beaucoup
changé on ne peut pas on peut très bien
aujourd'hui concevoir que le Conseil
constitutionnel est totalement différent
de celui qui a présidé au début de la 5e
République alors et cela pourquoi parce
qu'il y a eu a eu la première décision
de modification constitutionnelle
proposée par Giscard desesttin de
permettre à 60 députés et sénateurs de
saisir le Conseil maintenant les QPC ce
sont les citoyens et donc ça change tout
alors ma première question c'est comment
voyez-vous l'évolution du Conseil
constitutionnel pendant les 9 années
vous seriez appelé à y siéger c'est ma
première question ma deuxième question
concerne l'évolution de la jurisprudence
du Conseil constitutionnel et j'aimerais
avoir votre sentiment sur un point qui
me préoccupe notamment la position du
Conseil constitutionnel concernant le
cumul des mandats qui dans un premier
temps a reconnu que la loi
organique concernant cette modification
euh desèquelle touchit au Sénat devit
être adopté par le Sénat et maintenant
on nous dit que non finalement ça
concerne tous les parlementaires donc ce
n'est plus applicable au Sénat comment
vous voyez cela moi j'ai du mal à
comprendre cette interprétation et
j'aimerais avoir votre sentiment à ce
sujet car tout ce qui touche au Sénat en
loi organique me semble devoir appeler
la l'accord du Sénat donc 2e question 3è
question vous avez un parcours
extrêmement intéressant
et vous avez évidemment des
responsabilités politiques ce qui est un
plus pour moi mais il faut quand on est
dans une haute assemblée évidemment
oublier la subjectivité politique alors
comment envisagez-vous de faire pour
être bien certaine d'être totalement
objective dans vos choix de de haut
conseiller au Conseil
constitutionnel merci Monsieur cointa
monsieur Mercier oui euh merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente beaucoup de questions ont été
posées d'ailleurs ell se recoupent
largement et c'est tout à fait normal
moi je voudrais vous interroger sur un
point relativement simple pas sur les
textes dont vous aurez à connaître vous
pouvez pas nous dire avant comment vous
jugerez et heureusement que vous nous le
dites pas sinon il y aurz pas besoin de
délibérer du conseil
constitutionnel et la Constitution elle
est là vous devrez l'interpréter mais je
voudrais que vous nous
expliquiez
comment vous voyez votre entrée dans au
Conseil constitutionnel et comment vous
voyez votre rôle et qu'est-ce qui vous
inspire et plus particulièrement vous
êtes certes juriste mais le Conseil
constitutionnel comportait peu de
juristes au moment où ça jurispondance a
évolué il y avait pas que des juristes
en tous les cas où les grands décisions
ont été prises donc c'est très bien
d'être juriste on a plusieurs à l'être
aussi donc on va pas regretter ceux qui
sont juristes mais je crois que c'est
plus votre vision globale de
l'organisation politique de notre pays
que je voudrais que vous n disiez au
moment où vous allez entrer dans ce qui
est devenu peut-être pas encore
complètement mais plus largement une
cour constitutionnelle
merci Monsieur Merci monsieur Richard
oui monsieur le Président je suis frappé
en écoutant les collègues ce que le
l'opération laquelle nous livvrons est
initiatique naturellement pour la
personne qui vient répondre à nos
questions avant notre vote mais en
partie aussi pour la
commission car nous sommes en train de
découvrir au fond sur quel thème et sur
quel champ nous pouvons questionner la
personne que nous recevons parce
qu'évidment
si on lui demande d'avance comment elle
va juger cette question ne peut recevoir
qu'une réponse
et si on lui demande si elle connaît la
Constitution en principe la réponse
devrait être
positive donc moi je je je n'ai
qu'une un champ d'interrogation que je
voudrais adresser à Madame Boub
c'est le Conseil a jugé plus d'une
fois que ENF en tout cas indiqué dans
ses considérants plus d'une fois qu'il
ne détenait pas le pouvoir
d'appréciation qui revient au
législateur
seul évidemment un utile rappel
d'une d'une
évidence juridique d'abord et politique
ensuite il reste
que le Conseil est amené en permanence
euh à combiné des normes diverses
me rappelle
la la décision sur les sur les
nationalisations par
exemple où l'interprétation qui a pu
être tirée du des quelques mots de la
déclaration 89 de la juste et préalable
indemnité évidemment devenait toute une
théorie
économique donc votre réflexion sur au
fond le guide de pensée d'une
institution constitutionnelle comme
celle-ci lorsqu'elle fait le choix
d'associer plusieurs normes de droit
qu'est-ce qui peut guider cet
appréciation merci merci Monsieur
Richard Monsieur le
Comte merci monsieur le président madame
la Présidente certaines décisions du
Conseil
constitutionnel que ce soit sur des
annulations d'élection ou sur des
décisions politique très précise du
Parlement semble d'une certaine manière
heurter la
populaire
considérez-vous qui a pris la place de
Monsieur Mercier donc ça va se régler
bon alors Monsieur Vial vous êtes très
généreux de donner votre place mais
alors vous n'avez plus de place bon
j'interrompe Monsieur le Comte dans sa
démonstration madame lipiè voulait
parler oui alors Monsieur le Comte
pardonnez-moi parce que je trouvais là
une confusion je voulais
pas semble heur soit des décisions la
souveraineté populaire que ce soit des
annulations d'élections qui sont
pourtant prises avec beaucoup d'avance
ou des décisions qui ont été déjà
largement débattu au au Parlement et qui
ont fait l'objet de d'engagement
politique devant la devant devant
l'ensemble du peuple français
considérez-vous cela comme normal et si
vous considérez cela comme normal
comment l'expliquer simplement à la
population merci Monsieur lete par -
mooi de vous avoir interrompu devant cet
événement donc monsieur yest
ou merci monsieur le Président Madame
vous allez si vous êtes nommé rencontrer
au Conseil constitutionnel d'éminent
magistrat puisque il y a l'ancien
Premier président de la Cour de
cassation et l'ancien vice-président du
Conseil d'État et vous savez que le
quand j'entends Cour suprême moi je
pense que c'est pas exact parce et
d'ailleurs souvent la Cour de cassation
ou le Conseil d'État ce que considère un
petit peu Cour suprême et quand
j'entendais notre excellent collègue
Richard dire on dégage des principes le
Conseil d'État le fait depuis toujours à
partir du de de quelquefois des
principes généraux d'ailleurs qui sont
pas dans la constitution ou même dans
les préambules mais il y a les principes
généraux euh moi ma question madame la
madame c'est c'est
de
l'articulation entre le contrôle de
constitutionnalité avec bien entendu en
plus la présence de de la cour la Cour
de Justice des Communautés aujourd'hui
sur un certain nombre de sujets et les
jurisprudence de la Cour de cassation et
du conse surtout du surtout de la Cour
de cassation moins du Conseil
d'État puisque le le
le le Conseil
constitutionnel se ref fuse jusqu'à
présent à faire un contrôle de
conventionnalité et donc on se dit qu'il
y a quand même des yatus dans ce dans ce
système que nous avions posé lors de la
révision d'ailleurs constitutionnelle de
2008 à propos des
QPC et et donc j'aimerais avoir votre
votre sentiment sur ces risques quand
même de
contrariété de jurisprudence entre
notamment la Cour de cassation et le
Conseil constitutionnel avec ce qui s
passé une enfin refus de transmettre et
cetera desqpc enfin on a eu maintenant
c'est même si c'est un petit peu calmé
ça été quand même extrêmement
euh une vraie difficulté sur le plan du
droit merci Monsieur yest madame lipetz
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Rectrice je suis très heureuse bien
entendu de vous accueillir dans notre
assemblée qui manque un petit peu de
parité mais je crois que vous connaissez
la difficulté lorsqu'on est une femme
liée au fait d'être une femme dans une
assemblée masculine donc vous n'en serez
pas étonné moi j'ai juste une
question d'écologiste je voudrais savoir
quelle sera pour vous la la
complmentarité
ou ou l'articulation entre la Charte de
l'environnement dans notre campus
constitutionnel en rapport avec les
droits sociaux par exemple tel que
énuméré dans le préambule de la
constitution de 46 parce que le Conseil
constitutionnel pour l'instant n c'est
peu appuyé sur cette charte de
l'environnement qui pourtant est
certainement une question qui va devenir
centrale dans les années à venir
merci merci Madame Lipietz madame TASC
oui merci monsieur le Président
simplement un point que nous n'avons pas
encore soulevé c'est le poids de la
législation européenne et que
pensez-vous de la manière dont en l'état
actuel du droit les les normes
européennes sont intégrées au droit
national merci Tasca mes chers collègues
il n'y a plus de demande de parole je
propose qu'on s'en tienne là car déjà il
me semble que le nombre de questions
posées est assez important donc
euh madame Boubet je vais vous donner la
parole pour les apporter les réponses à
nos collègues
merci monsieur le Président merci pour
les les questions que vous avez posées
euh je commencerai très très brièvement
mais pour l'éliminer par répondre à une
question du Doyen Géard sur les cours
euh que j'ai pu faire j'ai comme tout
enseignant de droit public fait divers
cours de droit administratif
essentiellement mais également un peu de
droit constitutionnel du droit
communautaire et actuellement à
l'Institut d'études politiques je fais
essentiellement du droit européen droit
européen de la concurrence et le cours
de droit européen de première année
voilà je ne fais plus de droit
constitutionnel strictinu depuis
quelques temps déjà mais c'est un
bonheur que de
retrouver ces aspectsl de du droit
public je m'intéresserais peut-être
essentiellement dans
le le les la multiplicité des questions
que vous avez posé au fond à peut-être
ma perception du Conseil constitutionnel
et les évolutions qui ont eu lieu
puisque les uns et les autres vous avez
posé ce type de questions et ce faisant
j'esserai de de vous répondre je crois
effectivement et c'était une nécessité
que le Conseil constitutionnel a
énormément changé bon il a été créé au
début de la 5e République dans un but
très précis qui était de limiter les
pouvoirs du Parlement finalement et de
en tout cas de cadrer les pouvoirs du
Parlement je crois qu'aujourd'hui on est
n'est plus du tout dans cette optique là
et de ce fait l'évolution a été
extrêmement extrêmement marquée et il
est aujourd'hui non pas une cour suprême
pour répondre à une des dernières
questions qui qui a été posée non pas
une cour suprême mais réellement une
cour
constitutionnelle C alors c'est une
banalité aujourd'hui je crois que de
d'affirmer qu'il est une cour
constitutionnel il est à la fois par la
euh la procédure qui a été mise en œuvre
est grâce à la QPC qui a été introduite
par la révision de 2008 et qui je crois
a fondamentalement changé la nature du
conseil au fond cette
juridictionnalisation du Conseil
constitutionnel me semblait à la fois
nécessaire parce que la manière dont
elle s'est construite lui permet
réellement de devenir fondamentalement
un juge qui protège les droits et
libertés inscrites dans dans la
Constitution et je dirais que cet
aspect-là me semble être euh sans doute
un des aspects essentiels c'est moins un
juge de la procédure aujourd'hui qu'un
juge qui protège les droits et libertés
fondamentales qui les protège avec cette
exigence de conciliation puisque'au fond
dans ces divers droits vous l'avez
souligné monsieur Gor c'est très très
fréquemment et et d'autres encore c'est
très fréquemment une opération de
conciliation que le le juge doit se
livrer une opération de conciliation
entre des droits et des libertés et puis
l'intérêt général qui va se traduire
sous d'autres formes et cette opération
de conciliation de mon point de vue le
enfin je je vous parle je je n'ai jamais
travaillé par définition au Conseil
constitionnel mais de mon point de vue
cette opération de conciliation elle
doit se faire aussi en prenant appui sur
les travaux des
parlementaires sur des expertises mais
notamment sur les travaux des par
parlementaire qui je crois de ce point
de vue-là nous renseigne sur ce que veut
la représentation nationale
euh je dois dire d'ailleurs de ce point
de vue
que dans cette juridictionnalisation de
son contrôle dans cette évolution vers
une cour constitutionnelle il me semble
que le Conseil
constitutionnel protège
préserve le rôle des
euh juridictions des deux grandes
juridictions que sont la cour de la la
Cour de cassation et le Conseil d'État
il me semble que ce dessine d'après ce
que j'ai pu voir se
dessine une dissociation des tâches
euh en même temps qu'une association
d'ailleurs des cours suprêmes par le
biais de la QPC par la procédure de
renvoi les cours suprêmes sont associés
mais clairement les cours suprêmes sont
des juges négatifs de la
constitutionnalité alors que le Conseil
constitutionnel affirme son rôle de juge
positif de la constitutionnalité donc je
crois qu'il y a une clarification qui
s'opère d'une part je crois également
qu'il y a une complémentarité qui
s'opère entre le Conseil constitutionnel
et les les les les autres cours suprêmes
parce que très fréquemment je pense
notamment
euh à son appréciation que le juge peut
porter sur la constitutionnalité d'un
texte au travers de la QPC
il va le faire en s'appuyant sur la
jurisprudence de la Cour de cassation du
Conseil d'État donc il me semble qu'il y
a vraiment une prise en compte une
complémentarité qui peut s'effectuer et
puis pour répondre à Madame
taska
le il me semble qu'une des tâches
peut-être les plus importantes mais là
je vous dis ce à quoi je crois en tant
que citoyen je ne suis pas ici devant
vous en tant que citoyenne je ne suis
pas ici devant vous en tant que juge
constitutionn
moi je reprends assez volontiers ce que
le juge pescator a souligné à propos du
droit européen il a dit que c'était un
droit de l'intégration
et je pense que l'une des voies vers
lequell le Conseil constitutionnel va
devoir
aller pardonnez-moi je salue h Portelli
que je connais depuis très très
longtemps par la revue pouvoir dont je
vous parlais tout à l'heure donc il me
semble que l'une des tâches du juge
constitutionnel sera d'aller vers la
reconnaissance de cette intégration bien
sûr la constitution reste toujours ça a
été dit et je pense que c'est salutaire
la constitution reste au sommet de
l'ordre juridique français mais pour
autant on voit bien que le Conseil
constitutionnel a évolué il contrôle
aujourd'hui la conformité des lois de
transposition des directives à ces
directives bon sous réserve des
traditions constitutionnelles spécifique
de la France il a me semble-t-il une
attitude de plus en plus
intégratrice du travail fait par la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme certes
ce n'est pas les la l'Union européenne
mais il y a dans cette dimension là dans
cette évolution là un dialogue des juges
qui
s'installe Conseil constitutionnel Cour
de cassation Conseil d'État mais aussi
avec la Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme et avec la Cour de justice de
l'Union européenne qui me semble tout à
fait profitable
donc monsieur Richard vous m'avez
demandé au fond qu'est-ce qui
marquerait mon regard sur
euh le l'appréciation que nous pourrions
enfin que porte le Conseil
constitutionnel qu'est-ce qui fonderait
cette appréciation moi je crois beaucoup
à ce processus d'intégration vis-à-vis
notamment du droit européen je crois
croit également beaucoup à la capacité
d'interprétation du Conseil
constitutionnel je crois que le droit il
vaut essentiellement par son
interprétation de l'ensemble des juges
qu' s'agisse des juges du fond ou du
Conseil constitutionnel c'est évidemment
cela qui va le caractériser une
interprétation qui est fonderé donc sur
la conciliation des des principes
fondamentaux si vous me le permettez je
ne sais pas très bien de combien de
temps je dispose donc c'est peut-être un
petit peu difficile Jez le temps je
voudrais
également dire un mot par rapport aux
questions
de de Monsieur cointa je crois qui me
demandait si je serais en mesure
d'oublier ma vie politique antérieure
bon je crois de ce point de vue qu'il y
a une obligation évidemment de réserve
d'une part et d'impartialité et que
finalement là aussi la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme a eu l'occasion de
dire ce qu'était l'impartialité
impartialité subjective bon je ne sais
pas euh très bien comment on fait
concrètement mais clairement c'est
évidemment un devoir d'impartialité
qu'il faut être soumis et puis
impartialité objective qui là est plus
facile à contrôler je serais évidemment
très attentive à cette double double
impartialité voilà je voudrais également
peut-être répondre à Madame lipiet
lorsque vous évoquez madame
l'articulation avec la Charte de
l'environnement et avec euh le préambule
de 46 auquel vous avez fait référence
alors à vrai dire je n'avais jamais
pensé à l'articulation des deux sauf sur
un point et et et vous avez raison de ce
point de vue-là sur la question de
l'éducation puisque au fond laalinéa 13
du préambule de 46 pose le droit à
l'éducation hein un enseignement public
laïque gratuit obligatoire mais
également la Charte de l'environnement
évoque la question de l'éducation à
l'environ onnement donc il y a bien euh
des éléments sur lesquels on peut
combiner les deux bon je crois que le
Conseil constitutionnel là-dessus a déjà
affirmé reconnu la valeur intégrée la
Charte de l'environnement dans le bloc
de constitutionnalité il y a eu quelques
décisions à ce sujet il laisse le
législateur s'exprimer et intervient
ensuite dans dans ce cadre-là mais je
crois qu'il n'y a pas de difficulté sur
la reconnaissance de la valeur de la
Charte de l'environnement c'est
peut-être plus difficile d'en traduire
euh les dans mesurer les traductions
pratiques la mise en œuvre voilà euh
alors je ne sais pas s'il y a d'autres
points sur
lesquels donc monsieur Quinta vous
évoquiez l'évolution du Conseil
constitutionnel dans les 9 années à
venir je l'ai dit pour moi c'est surtout
vers ce dialogue des juge que doit aller
le Conseil constitutionnel en restant
sur la mise en place qui a été faite à
l'heure actuel de mon point de vue
c'est-à-dire clairement un juge de la
constitutionnalité des juges de la
conventionnalité du fond et des
dialogues entre l'ensemble de ces juges
peut-être n'ai-je pas répondu aux
questions du Doyen Géard sur les
opinions dissidante la QPC les la
présence des anciens présidents de la
République bon je ne suis pas le
constituant sur le dernier point sur la
présence des anciens présidents de la
République je ne suis pas le constituant
ou alors nous le sommes tous
et je dois dire
que je répondrai de deux manières les
fait
montre que les anciens présidents de la
République sont relativement peu
présents d'abord pendant très longtemps
il y en a eu aucun et aujourd'hui pour
les raisons que nous savons le président
Sarkozi ne siège pas en raison du
contrôle sur ses compte de campagne le
président Chirac est assez absent pour
les raisons que nous devinons également
et le Président giscardestin j'ai un peu
regardé sa présence il est relativement
peu présent donc la majeure partie la
très grande partie des décisions du
conseil sont rendu hors présence des
anciens présidents de la République je
crois que les faits qualifient eux-mêmes
la situation par ailleurs il me semble
que la
juridictionnalisation de la procédure
pourrait effectivement conduire le
constituant à s'interroger sur le
maintien de de cette présence mais je ne
souhaite pas ici aller au-delà sur la
QPC je crois que je je ne sais pas si je
vous ai répondu enfin c'est une
innovation majeur qui était demandé
depuis longtemps qui je crois est un
vrai succès quantitatif euh si euh euh
j'ai bien lu il y a eu 5000 demandes de
QPC 1500 transmises par les cours
suprêmes et qui ont donné lieu je crois
au 31 décembre 2012 à 250 décisions donc
on est face dont euh 250 décisions dont
je crois 54 % euh de conformité euh 16 %
de conformité sous réserve et cetera
donc bon je crois que c'est un vrai
succès quantitatif c'est pour les
raisons que j'ai développé devant vous
tout à l'heure et que je ne reprendrai
pas me semble-t-il un succès qualitatif
également parce que
fondamentalisation du contrôle
sur les droits parce que claire
distinction entre ce rôle de juge
constitutionnel et les cours suprêmes il
me semble que c'est un succès même si
bien sûr à la marge on peut toujours
améliorer cette procédure voilà et euh
vous aviez une dernière question sur le
mode de désignation des membres du
Conseil constitutionnel et bien euh
voilà j'espère que je serai tout à fait
satisfaite de ce mode de désignation
après votre
vote bien merci Madame j'ai cru voir que
Monsieur Colomba et Monsieur mard
n'avent pas forcément le sentiment que
vous avez répondu à leurs questions a
été court Gorse peut-être partage-t-il
le même sentiment alors comme nous
sommes très attachés à ce que chacun
reçoive sa réponse je me permets de
insister auprès de vous par rapport aux
questions de nos
collègues alors la question de Monsieur
Colomba n'est-ce pas monsieur Gor avait
une question complémentaire c'est ça
monsieur Gor pard je je merci monsieur
le Président deavir donnner la parole
mais j'avais posé ces questions assez
précises sur euh le respect du droit à
la vie et la liberté individuelle sur la
question du cumul des mandats qui sont
des questions qui vont rentrer dans le
débat et donc dans l'intervention du
Conseil cel auquel vous ne pouvez pas ou
ne souhaitez pas répondre et si je l'ai
fait c'était pour souligner l'ambiguité
de la démarche dans laquelle nous sommes
engagés euh notre commission et moi je
m'en réjouis est amené à donner un avis
sur le choix d'un membre du Conseil
consel c'est un progrès pour le
Parlement le problème c'est que le vote
que nous pouvons émettre est un vote à
la majorité qualifiée négative donc il
n'a pas de réelle incidence il faudrait
vraiment qu'il se passe des choses
considérable pour que c'est puisse avoir
un impact et les questions que nous
pouvons poser ne peuvent pas être des
questions politiques alors que nous
sommes une assemblée politique les
questions politiques sont cell au fond
qu'aura jugé enroit le Conseil
constitutionnel et si on demande son
avis au Parlement c'est sans doute qu'il
souhaite savoir dans sa majorité quelle
sera la position de celui qu'andomme sur
les grandes questions qui l'intéressent
nous ne sommes pas un juris de concours
nous ne pouvons pas nous prononcer sur
la qualité personnelle ou
professionnelle de Madame béoubé tout ce
que nous pouvons faire évidemment c'est
donner un sentiment sur l'orientation
générale que peut prendre euh le gouvern
dans ces nominations moi je me suis
réjoui qu'on fasse le choix de la parité
en tout cas de la renforcer et sur les
orientations qui vont être soutenu au
Conseil constitutionnel don de deux
choses l'une ou bien nous avons à faire
avec le Conseil constitutionnel un
tribunal qui doit effectivement
fonctionner de manière indépendante du
politique et dans ce cas-là la question
de son mode de nomination reste posé et
le Parlement n'a pas intervenir dans le
choix de ses membres parce que nous ne
pouvons pas poser des questions qui
soient des questions strictement
juridique ce n'est pas d're rôle ou bien
effectivement le Conseil constitutionnel
assume pour une part sa fonction poli
politique et dans ce cas-là les
conditions de nomination de son momre
doivent permettre un débat sur le fond
sur des questions comme la fin de vie
sur des questions comme le cumulle des
mandats sur d'autres question sinon
effectivement le rôle des parlementaires
est comment dire résumé à un entretien
convivial et j'espère courtois sur
lequel nous n'avons finalement aucune
prise et il s'agit simplement de valider
par une forme de simulacre de discussion
au fond une un processus qui reste un
processus sous le contrôle de l'exécutif
très bien on l'assume ou le président de
du Sénat ou de la assemblé moi j'aurais
tendance à contester ce mode de
désignation voilà je voulais juste faire
ressortir ces points c'était pas pour
vous mettre dans la Bara madame sur ces
points pr merci Monsieur monsieur Gor
j'observe que les remarques que vous
faites s'appliquent au moins autant au
Sénat enfin ça s'adresse au Sénat voir
aux constituants voire aux personnes qui
ont imaginé le présent dispositif qu'à
madame Boubé mes chers collègues il faut
que nous tenions l'horaire ce matin ça
va être très difficile donc monsieur
Portelli a demandé la parole puis je
donnerai la parole à Madame Boubé pour
réponse à Monsieur mzard monsieur
Colomba monsieur Gor et Monsieur
Portelli et puis je vous propose qu'on
arrête monsieur Portelli excusez-moi
retard moi j'étais en train de faire mon
droit constitutionnel euh je voulais
poser une question à Madame oui tout à
fait cul autorisé par la Constitution et
si vous voulez la changer vous changerez
la Constitution pour une fois vous la
voterez peut-être
simplement j'avais une question qui
était une question
pratique moi ce qui me frappe le plus
c'est on avait posé la question lors de
la révision 2008 malheureusement ceux
qui avaient proposé comme moi qu'on
modifie le texte de la Constitution
n'avait pas été suivi ce qui me frappe
le plus c'est les délai très brefs dans
lesquels le conseil est amené à prendre
ses décisions ce qui pose la qualité de
son travail la question de la qualité de
son travail lorsqu'on voit le temps que
prend la Cour constitutionnelle fédérale
allemande pour examiner par exemple le
traité de Lisbonne ou même une simple
loi fédéral qui est soumis à son
contrôle et qu'on voit que le Conseil
constitutionnel na des délis extrêmement
brefs pour faire le même type
d'exercice la question euh qui se pose
c'est de savoir dans quelles conditions
vous allez
travailler bien madame Boubé
euh oui merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur Mar avait posé une question sur
la question de la décentralisation et du
rôle de l'État je
cro il me semble alors je je ne sais
pardonnez-moi je ne me souviens plus
exactement ce qui était attendu
peut-être c'est plus simple que Monsieur
mard me repose sa question alors
Monsieur
mard madame pour moi une non réponse
constitue une réponse donc je n'en
demandais pas plus non mais là là ce
n'était pas une intention de ma part de
ne pas vous
répondre il y avait cisation et rôle de
l'État il y avait scrutin unominal et
scrutin proportionnel voilà que que
répondre je considère évidemment que
dans toutes les hypothèses il y a sur le
deuxième point c'est une forme choisie
par le constituant ou par le législateur
évidemment que d'instaurer ces types de
de scrutin qui me semble reflét dans des
cas différents des le respect du
suffrage universel de la même manière
mais ça s'applique à des situations
différentes je ne sais pas très bien ce
que vous vous attendiez de manière
précise he pardonnez-moi
mais la question que posait monsieur
Portelli sur la brièveté des délais
certes les délais sont brefs puisque
nous sommes à un mois sur le contrôle à
postériori à priori et puis à 3 mois sur
le la
QPC les délais sont extrêmement brefs
mais c'est aussi me semble-t-il ce qui
fait que le juge constitutionnel reste
cantonné dans euh sa fonction de juge de
constitutionnalité n'intervient pas en
tant que juge de la conventionnalité et
c'est ce qui lui permet aussi de
s'appuyer sur les cours suprêmes bon
c'est un élément de réponse que de
s'appuyer sur cette briveté pour on peut
aussi dire que la briveté fait que les
les rédactions des décisions sont
elles-même la brièveté des délais fait
que les rédactions des décisions sont
elles-mêmes assez brèves n'y figurent
pas les opinions dissidente on en a
parlé tout à l'heure et d'une certaine
manière pour le travail collectif pour
l'unité de la décision je trouve que
c'est plutôt à ce stade et de là où je
suis plutôt un élément positif mais on
peut avoir évidemment une opinion
différente voilà Monsieur Colomba euh
m'a posé la question de savoir si le
Conseil constitutionnel avait une
dimension politique et jusqu'où
euh tout dépend du sens que l'on donne
auopolitique
euh si la politique c'est la Vie dans la
Cité alors oui bien sûr le Conseil
constitutionnel a une dimension
politique si on a une acception plus
restrictive je n'en suis pas sûre je
dirais que le Conseil constitutionnel je
je reprends un peu une formule qui a été
utilisée il utilise plus la gomme que le
crayon aurait dit l'actuel président du
Conseil constitutionnel mais pardon
oui mais disais-je s'il n'utilise pas le
BIC il utilise parfois le crayon à
papier il me semble qu'il y a assez
fréquemment tout de même un renvoi vers
le législateur possible c'est notamment
le cas dans le cadre de la QPC ou
lorsque la décision s'applique avec dé
laai permettent au législateur de
reprendre la main de réécrire le texte
il me semble qu'il y a là un élément qui
au-delà
de ce que vous avez évoqué c'est-à-dire
du pouvoir général d'appréciation du
Conseil constitutionnel qui ne serurait
être identique à celui du législateur on
on a là un élément de retour vers le
législateur qui me semble être
intéressant et qui finalement et moi
enfin il me semble que c'est un point
sur lequel on doit être très attentif
donne les législateurs sa vraie
place
bien mes chers collègues je crois qu'il
me reste à remercier madame Boubé pour
pour être venue répondre à nos
différentes questions et à vous
remercier aussi pour votre participation
à ce débat nous allons enchaîner tout de
suite avec Madame
maestrachi c'est moi qui vous remercie
mesdames et messieurs je vous souhaite
une bonne
journée nous avons l'honneur de
recevoir Madame Nicole maestrachi je lui
souhaite la bienvenue au nom de chacune
et chacun d'entre vous mad madame la
première
présidente nous savons en particulier et
pour un certain nombre d'entre nous nous
avons pu voir et entendre
vos vos
propos lors de la conférence de
consensus puisque vous avez
présidé pendant plusieurs mois
l'instance qui a
préparé cette manifestation importante
et je le dis parce que cela a beaucoup
intéressé et je pense que les le
résultat des travaux euh qui sera
présenté aujourd'hui même je crois au
Premier ministre ou peut-être demain euh
sera euh suivi avec beaucoup de soins
par euh notre commission euh mais nous
ne sommes pas là pour parler de cela
encore que cela fait partie désormais de
votre biographie donc Madame la première
présidente je je vais vous
demander si vous le voulez bien de vous
présenter et peut-être aussi de nous
dire ce que quels sont vos vos idées par
rapport au Conseil constitutionnel car
le Conseil constitutionnel et vous le
savez un sujet de débat entre nous et
plus largement pendant peut-être une
vingtaine de minutes ou un quart d'heure
20 minutes et puis après je pourrais
donner la parole à nos collègues qui
manque pas de vous poser de nombreuses
questions donc Madame la première
présidente vous avez la
parole merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs
euh je vais me présenter mon parcours
très rapidement
euh je suis un magistrat de l'ordre
judiciaire j'ai toujours été magistrat
du siège je suis
entré dans la magistrature en
1979 euh auparavant j'ai étis quelques
temps avocat et en particulier
euh collaborateur d'un avocat au Conseil
d'État et à la Cour de cassation euh
avant de passer le concours de la
magistrature où j'ai exercé un certain
nombre de fonctions presque toutes les
fonctions du siège à l'exception des
fonctions de juge d'instruction euh j'ai
été en particulier juge des enfants et
juge l'application des peines à une
époque où ces fonctions n'étaient pas
les plus valorisées de la magistrature
mais euh j'ai appris d'abord c'est des
fonctions qui euh sont des fonctions du
du temps qui passe de l'évolution des
personnes et donc c'est des fonctions
qui permettent de suivre l'évolution des
personnes et de se rendre compte de des
des conséquences euh des décisions que
nous rendons j'ai été juge l'application
des peines à l'époque à une époque où le
l'application des peines n'était pas
encore judiciarisé et où en voyait très
peu d'avocats ù peu de personnes
s'intéresser à ces fonctions qui ont
pris depuis une autre ampleur j'ai été
également conseillé à la cour d'appel
président de chambre à la cour d'appel
de Paris et j'ai j'ai traité plutôt
contentieux commercial les contrats
commerciaux et le le droit des
procédures collectives j'ai été
également chargé de la coordination des
juges de l'application des peines à
cette époque euh j'ai été présidente du
tribunal de Melin tribunal de de la
région parisienne pendant plusieurs
années et je suis actuellement première
présidente de la cour d'appel de de
rouan et j'ai pu dans ses fonctions de
de chef de juridiction ou de chef de
cour qui sont des des fonctions
euh assez complexes parce que en fait on
doit à la fois veiller à ce que la
justice soit correctement rendue sur le
territoire correctement ce qui veut dire
dans des délais correctes avec une
accessibilité suffisante pour les
justiciables avec un accueil un accès au
droit qui soit satisfaisant et puis en
même temps euh et bien on ne dirige que
des gens indépendant et donc
euh c'est une c'est un exercice qui est
relativement difficile surtout dans une
période budgétaire particulièrement
contrainte j'ai exercé également des
fonctions administratives euh j'ai été
euh en
83 au ministère de la Justice à la
direction de l'administration
pénitentiaire où j'étais chargé d'un
bureau qui a mis en œuvre notamment le
travail d'intérêt général qui venait
d'être voté à l'unanimité par le
Parlement et
euh c'était une un bureau qui s'appelait
bureau de la participation communautaire
qui devait justement ouvrir
l'administration pénitentière
à aux associations aux autres services
publics et de préparer afin de mieux
préparer la réinsertion des détenu j'ai
été assez brièvement mais c'est une
expérience importante conseiller
technique à la Délégation
interministérielle à la sécurité
routière où j'ai touché du doigt la les
difficiles politique publique
interministérielle avec la difficile
gestion de logique contradictoire hein
qui sont à la fois des
logiques de prévention de santé publique
mais aussi des logiques
industrielles
et et puis comment on on peut faire
évoluer l'opinion publique par rapport à
des questions comme la sécurité routière
ou par exemple l'attitude des personnes
que je pouvais voir dans une audience
de d'infraction routière en 80 n'avait
absolument pas la même attitude que
celle que j'ai pu voir 20 ans après ce
qui prouve que une politique publique
c'est la loi et puis c'est aussi toutes
les les mesures de prévention les
politiques publiques qui accompagnent la
loi euh j'ai été également euh dans un
cabinet ministériel de 88 à 90 où je
suivais les questions de protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse les questions
relatives aux étrangers à la politique
de la ville et un certain nombre de
textes qui n'étaient pas d'origine qui
n'étaient pas des textes du ministère de
la Justice à l'origine euh et puis tout
ce qui concernait le le milieu ouvert de
l'administration pénitentiaire et euh
j'ai été euh présidente de la Mission
interministérielle de lutte contre les
drogues et les toxicomanies euh de de 98
à 2002 où j'ai essayé de
euh d'une part de
de de de mettre à disposition de de tout
le monde à la fois l'opinion publique et
puis les les décideurs les éléments du
débat et en partie
particulier sur la base de de données
scientifiques suffisamment validé et
puis ça a été l'occasion aussi
de s'intéresser à toutes les substances
psychoactives disons et pas seulement
les drogues illicites c'est-à-dire
l'alcool et le tabac et l'alcool en
particulier qui faisait l'objet d'une
politique relativement modeste
contenu de pourtant de des difficulté
qu'elle entraîne
euh ce qu'on constate quotidiennement
dans la juridiction
euh j'ai j'ai me suis intéressé
également aux questions de de recherche
à plusieurs reprises d'abord quand
j'étais à la Mission interministérielle
de lutte contre la drogue où j'ai
beaucoup développé le la la recherche et
les connaissances en développant
l'Observatoire français des drogues et
toxychomanie et et et le des programmes
de recherche de telle sorte qu'on ait
les éléments de les éléments du débat et
puis aussi j'avais été chargé en 91
d'une
d'une d'un rapport enfin d'une mission
sur la recherche au ministère de la
Justice qui a entraîné la création du
groupement d'intérêt public droit et
justice qui aujourd'hui programme la
recherche au ministère de la Justice et
puis par ailleurs j'ai été pendant
plusieurs années présidente de la
Fédération Nationale des Associations de
insertion sociale en plus de mes
activités professionnelles et qui est
une fédération qui regroupe
850 association d'insertion qui gère les
centres d'hébergement et les centres
d'accueil pour demandeurs d'asile et les
les structures d'insertion par
l'activité économique et je dirais que
ce que je retiens de cette de cette
expérience c'est et à cette occasion
j'ai à nombreuses reprises été entendu
par diverses commissions ici
et à l'Assemblée nationale sur
différents projets de loi mais ce que je
retiens surtout de cette période c'est
la difficile accession d'un certain
nombre de personnes au droit et euh
pendant cette période il y a eu toute
l'émergence de la problématique du non
recours qui existait avant mais dont on
avait moins conscience c'est-à-dire que
un certain nombre de personnes qui ont
droit à à un certain nombre de
prestations un certain nombre de droit
en fait ni n ont pas recours ça a
particulièrement été mise en évidence
sur le RSA mais c'est àquellement vrai
pour la droit la loi sur le droit au
logement opposable ou sur pour la loi
sur la CMU et ce qui fait réfléchir
aussi à la manière dont les lois sont
appliquées voilà pour ce qui concerne
mon parcours mais évidemment je suis
prête à à répondre à toutes vos
questions s'agissant du Conseil
constitutionnel bon d'abord comme vous
pouvez le le constater je ne suis pas
une constitutionnaliste et je ne
prétends pas l'être même si évidemment
si
j'étais désigné
je je ferais tout pour accueillir
acquérir toutes les compétences
nécessaires je suis plutôt une juriste
de de droit privé et euh j'ai j'ai
cependant beaucoup
plus disons euh
travailler avec le droit constitutionnel
ou intégrer le droit constitutionnel
dans mes pratiques à la suite de la
réforme de 2008 et de la mise en œuvre
de la question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité puisque j'ai eu
l'occasion de transmettre certaines
questions prioritaires de
constitutionnalité euh à la Cour de
cassation et euh et
donc je me suis réjouie en tant que
magistrat de l'ordre judiciaire de cette
réforme et de Laib ité d'une plus grande
proximité en tous les cas entre les
citoyens et le Conseil constitutionnel
et je me suis réjoui aussi de la
possibilité de contrôle à postériori de
la loi parce que la loi le contrôle à
priori c'est une chose mais le contrôle
à postériori ça permet aussi de regarder
comment une loi s'applique et je crois
je pense que les magistrats de l'ordre
judiciaire sont particulièrement
sensibles à la manière dont une loi
s'applique on sait très bien bien qu'une
loi ce n'est
pas quelque chose de désincarné qu' le
sujet de droit c'est pas
euh quelqu'un de de désincarné mais
c'est quelqu'un de de vivant et que donc
euh la loi pour l'appliquer bien on
tient compte nécessairement d'un
contexte d'une situation
socio-économique d'une personnalité et
euh d'un équilibre des pouvoirs voilà
donc
c'est pourquoi je je me réjouis beaucoup
de l'opportunité qui m'est donné de
rejoindre cette cours qui n'est pas une
cour suprême mais qui devient peut-être
une cour
constitutionnelle merci Madame la
première
présidente je vais donner la parole donc
à nos collègues j'ai Monsieur
Michel monsieur
Géard alors Monsieur Gor monsieur Béchu
monsieur
cointa monsieur Colomba monsieur
leer Monsieur le
Comte monsieur rich monsieur
Richard alors y a-t-il des
regrets non pour l'instant il n'y en a
pas alors Monsieur
Michel merci monsieur le Président
madamech votre passé de magistrat euh
m'amène à vous poser cette question vous
l'avez dit vous-même le Conseil
aujourd'hui continue à contrôler à
priori les textes de loi par rapport à
la Constitution et à postériori par les
QPC pourquoi y y a-t-il deux procédures
différentes est-ce que cela ne vous gêne
pas et notamment pourquoi lorsque le
Conseil contrôle a
priori il s'affranchit de toutes ses
Ines et il statue en dehors même de la
sesine qui lui est fait fait est-ce que
cela vous paraît normal un juge
judiciaire ne peut pas statuer en dehors
de sa saisine on le Conseil le fait pour
ma part je trouve que c'est absolument
inadmissible
inadmissible inadmissible notamment le
lorsque le Conseil constitutionnel
décide que tel article serait un
cavalier alors que il a été voté à
l'unanimité par le
Parlement merci Monsieur Michel monsieur
Géard merci Monsieur le présid président
d'abord je me félicite des succès que
rencontre la cour d'appel de rouan
puisque le premier président de la Cour
de cassation en est issu et que nous
risquons d'avoir bientôt un membre
éminent de la cour d'appel de Ran
devenir membre du Conseil
constitutionnel maladame le premier
Président je suis heureux de vous saluer
je vous rencontre régulièrement dans les
séances solennelles de rentrer au
tribunal du Havre là nous nous
rencontrons ailleurs madame le Président
le premier Président je voudrais
souligner une chose qui me paraît un peu
inquiétante pour l'avenir du Conseil
constitutionnel c'est que la majorité va
revenir à des
magistrats nous allons avoir en effet
deux magistrats de la Cour de cassation
puisque vous êtes membr de la Cour de
cassation d'ailleursf de l'ordre
judiciaire au moins trois du Conseil
d'État un de la Cour des comptes ça me
paraît donner une image du Conseil
constitutionnel de plus en plus
porter vers le juridictionnel et de
moins en moins vers d'autres
préoccupations par exemple il n'y aura
qu'un seul professeur de droit il y aura
de moins en moins de représentants des
professions juridiques ça me paraît un
peu inquiétant à terme alors je voudrais
savoir quel est votre point de vue sur
cette
question c'est tout je n'ai pas d'autre
question à merci Monsieur Géard monsieur
Gor merci monsieur le Président vous me
pardonnerez de rester dans le même état
d'esprit que que tout à l'heure mais
j'ai écouté madame maestraci nous
présenter sa biographie professionnelle
qui évidemment est excellente et je
crois qu'on doit saluer les choix du
président de la République comme du
président du Sénat qui ont eu évidemment
la la vigilance c'est de nous présenter
des candidatures sur lequelles nous ne
pouvons formuler me semble-t-il mes
collègues de l'opposition comme moi-même
aucune objection quant à la compétence
supposé de chacun de chux qui nous sont
présentés ce qui montre bien là encore
je reviens ce sujet la nature très
particul de l'exercice auquel nous
sommes amenés à nous livrer puisque nous
n'allons pas effectivement commenter le
parcours professionnel de Madame
maestrai pas plus que nous l'avons fait
pour Madame Boué que nous ne pouvons pas
lui poser des questions sur la manière
don l'envisage de juger tel ou tel sujet
de fond sur lequel évidemment nous nous
avons une responsabé politique et qui
nous concerne nous sommes donc les uns
et les autres amenés à chercher des
questions qui nous permettent d'occuper
agréablement cette séance sauf à
supposer naturellement que nous ne
voulions pas exercer je vois madame
taska n'est pas d'accord mais c'est bien
comme ça que les choses se passent car
quel est le pouvoir réel du Parlement
dans cette affaire il faut nous ayons
une majorité qualifiée négative pour
éventuellement refuser une candidature
je comprends bien qu'on a voulu en
faisant cela réparer les abus que nous
avons connu dans les années 60 70
peut-être 80 où effectivement il y
aurait eu beaucoup à dire sur une
nomination et j'aurais pas la cruauté
densité mais aujourd'hui que nous sommes
dans une situation nouvelle on pourrait
supposer qu'on aille jusqu'au bout de la
réflexion sur ce qu'est le rôle du
Conseil constitutionnel le doyen Gard
vient de le rappeler est-ce au fond une
instance purement juridictionnelle
garde-t-elle une dimension politique je
crois que oui c'est un mélange des deux
il faut donc l'assumer et il faudrait
par les modalités de nomination tirer
les conséquences voilà simplement ce que
je vous dire ce n'est pas une question
c'est une observation qui a l'air de
consterner certains de mes amis mais
pour le coup moi je suis ravi de pouvoir
le faire parce qu'on nous appelait tout
à l'heure les citoyens incommodes je ne
pense pas que ce soit être totalement
satisfaisant comme parlementaire et
comme sénateur d'être ici simplement
pour donner son Laval à une décision qui
a été prise ailleurs aussi satisfaisante
soit-elle je tiens à le
dire bien merci Monsieur GS comme
précédemment vous vous êtes adressé
aussi bien à
l'Assemblée qu'à madame la première
présidente qu'à d'ailleurs des autorités
qui ne sont pas ici représentées bien
alors Monsieur
Béchu merci Monsieur le le Président je
partage l'avis de l'orateur précédent et
d'un certain nombre qui se sont exprimés
auparavant sur le caractère imparfait de
ce système cela dit je préfère avoir
l'occasion de m'entretenir et de pouvoir
entendre les membres à venir du Conseil
constitutionnel et qu'on dispose d'une
sorte de
procédure même compliquée à
réaliser qui nous permettent le cas
échéant d'empêcher un choix qui aurait
été particulièrement peu éclairé de la
part d'une des autorités politiques de
ce pays plutôt que de ne disposer
d'aucun processus quand on regarde ce
qu'est le ce qu'est le parcours de
Madame maestrachi on se dit que
finalement elle a plus à perdre de
l'exercice qu'autre chose puisque sur la
base de son CV on pourrait être tenté
par une forme d'une unanimité compte
tenu de la variété de ses expériences
j'aimerais
néanmoins lui poser comme elle a eu
plusieurs vies trois questions la
première en qualité de chef de
juridiction sur la tentation aujourd'hui
d'aller réouvrir un certain nombre de
tribunaux l'organisation de la justice
malgré tout est
une est une compétence importante et son
avis de praticienne m'importe la seconde
elle est d'actualité c'est la question
en ce qui concerne les drogues de la
question de l'éventuel
pénalisation ou de la
contreventionnalisation c'est peut-être
plutôt le terme qu'il faut utiliser
d'une partie des bon parce que sa double
expérience euh de magistrat et
spécifique sur cette question fait que
je seraai intéressé pour avoir de
manière très succinte euh sa réponse sur
la sur la manière de voir les choses
enfin euh vous avez évoqué
madame la question des droits qui n'étit
pas revendiqués par les citoyens plus
exactement la façon de le formuler peut
induire la réponse mais en tout cas
l'existence d'un certain nombre de
droits dont certains bénéficiaires ne
bénéficiez
pas il y a la question
juridique et puis il y a
derrière
celle de l'effectivité d'un certain
nombre de
textes cette
effectivité est-ce que vous considérez
que le Conseil constitutionnel peut not
notamment au travers
des au travers des nouveaux dispositifs
qui qui existent je pense par exemple au
PPC devenir finalement une forme de juge
de l'application des lois c'est-à-dire y
compris aller se pencher dans un certain
nombre de cas sur l'existence des textes
permettant l'effectivité de ce qui a été
voté par le législateur ou
pas merci merci Monsieur Béchu monsieur
cointa
oui madame la première présidente comme
vous le savez on dit d'une manière un
peu humoristique qu'en droit la faute
n'existe que quand elle est constatée ce
qui signifie qu'il suffit de faire en
sorte qu'on ne puisse pas la constater
pour qu'on puisse agir impunément en
toute illégalité c'est un peu ce qui
s'est fait avec notre Constitution
jusqu'en 2008 avec les QPC question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité les
citoyens avaient des droits garantis
mais il ne pouvait pas protester si on
l'est violait puisque il ne pouvait pas
se plaindre à l'autorité responsable
autrement dit le Conseil constitutionnel
maintenant on le peut mais il se trouve
qu'il y a le filtre des juridictions or
l'expérience m'a démontré que il y a un
certain nombre de juridictions notamment
administrative mais aussi judiciaire euh
qui font des filtres plus que filtres
c'est-à-dire qu'il ne transmettent pas
les QPC ou très très peu en estimant que
ce n'est pas nécessaire il y a donc donc
un jugement dès le départ qui revient à
vicier le dispositif alors moi je
souhaiterais ce que à la fois comme
personne désignée par le Président de la
République pour siéger au Conseil
constitutionnel et à la fois comme
première présidente de cour d'appel n
dire ce que vous en penser et comment
vous voyez l'évolution des choses pour
que l'on puisse véritablement avoir un
filtre c'est vrai qui soit raisonnable
mais qui ne soit pas
excessif merci Monsieur Quinta monsieur
Colomba
oui madame d'abord dire que semble-t-il
à ce que vous nous avez dit votre
connaissance du monde d'ambas est tout à
fait impressionnante donc c'est plutôt
bon signe si vous siégez au monde d'en
haut
et je voudrais poser une question la
première c'est l'expérience montre que
le le Conseil constitutionnel a été
amené à prendre des décisions
franchement politiques est-ce que vous
pensez
que il est dans son rôle en le faisant
voir que ça peut être peut-être
inéluctable et si oui quelle doit être
la la limite et ensuite vous avez évoqué
tout à l'heure le problème du du droit
au logement opposable et vous avez dit
il s'agit de la manière dont les lois
sont appliquées est-ce que c'est la
manière dont les lois sont appliquées
qui estfin que que vous contrôlez ou le
fait que dans ce cas-là la loi est venue
suppléer
un manque de politique de création de
logement parce que qu'est-ce que c'est
que le fonctionnement réel du droit au
posable logement ça revient à établir
des priorités entre les gens qui
cherchent un un logement donc ça me
paraît un
exemple fait tout à fait significatif où
la loi bah vient tenir lieu finalement
de politique pratique on retrouve donc
la pratique donc j'aimerais avoir votre
votre sentiment sur justement cette
articulation entre entre la loi et puis
ses effets réels sur et non seulement
réel pas seulement décoratif sur le
terrain merci Monsieur Colomba monsieur
leerci monsieur le Président tout
d'abord moi je suis un peu moins
pessimiste que mes collègues sur
l'utilité de ce passage devant les
commissions compétentes de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Sénat je crois que
l'utilité joue en amont c'est-à-dire que
l'autorité de nomination sachant
effectivement qu'il y a ce passage
devant les commissions s'organise pour
que effectivement ce passage ne ne
provoque pas effectivement de problème
et j'ai d'ailleurs en tête un exemple où
avant même la révision constitutionnelle
une autorité de nomination avait changé
sa proposition parce que la loi avait
prévu effectivement le passage devant
les commissions des lois compétentes
madame je souhaiterais vous poser deux
questions la première question une
question de méthode sur les méthodes de
de du Conseil
constitutionnel Conseil constitutionnel
c'est malgré tout le censeur des lois
donc déjà
sa sa relation avec le législateur est
une relation complexe avec les questions
prioritaires de constitutionnalité il
lui arrive effectivement de donner des
injonctions au législateur vous me
changez ce texte avant telle date tout
ça n'arrange pas effectivement le le
problème de de de de la complexité des
relations entre législateur et Conseil
constitutionnel est-ce que vous ne
pensez pas qu'il y aurait une
possibilité qui permettrait de de de
d'améliorer un peu les choses et qui
serait au moins dans les hypothèses
classiques de cesine du c'està-dire les
hypothèses de saisine du conseil d'une
loi qui n'est pas encore promulguée le
fait d'entendre par exemple les
rapporteurs de chacune des assemblées
moi j'ai regretta souvent lorsque
j'étais rapporteur que il n'y ait pas eu
ce contact qui aurait permis peut-être
d'expliciter l'intention du législateur
et d'éviter sur certains points
effectivement des des censures qui à mon
avis n'était pas indispensable une
deuxième question qui n'a rien à voir
lorsque le Conseil constitutionnel a été
créé effectivement c'était un outil de
ce qu'on appelait un des outils de ce
qu'on appelait à l'époque la
rationalisation du parlementarisme et il
avait un rôle à jouer
dans la sauvegarde des domaines de la
loi et du Règlement après tout le
Conseil d'État sensur des décrets
protecteur du domaine de la loi et
inversement le Conseil constitutionnel
sensur de la loi se trouvera être le
protecteur du domaine du règlement
est-ce que vous estimez pas que cette
compétence ancienne qui est aujourd'hui
un peu obsolète est peut-être un peu
trop obsolète merci merci Monsieur le
SER Monsieur le
Comte merci monsieur le
Président le Conseil constitutionnel
exerce son son rôle de juge d'un certain
nombre d'élections les élection
législative en particulier il le fait
assez souvent en prononçant des
décisions en 1995 il y a eu un débat
assez important
sur la l'élection présidentielle qui est
sortie du conseil puisque certains
membres du conseil ont témoigné sur ce
qui avait pu se dire al ma question est
la suivante une élection présidentielle
est-elle
invalidable merci Monsieur le Comte
monsieur
Richard Président je
risquerais également ou deux
commentaires sur ce que nous sommes en
train de faire là pour essayer de les
rendre un peu moins mélancolique que ce
que j'ai
entendu d'abord sur la relation entre le
conseil constitutionnel le Parlement
c'est depuis
euh 67 ans qu'il existe une instance
commun constitutionnelle puis qu'il en
existait une sous la 4e
République le Parlement
tarde le Parlement tarde à prendre
conscience qui n'est pas seu à la tête
de l'État de
droit et qu' a une autre
institution qui garantit un élément
fondamental pas le seul de l'État de
droit et et qu'il peut être amené à le
garantir y compris contre des décisions
du pouvoir législatif je crois que
l'État de droit a sa complexité il a sa
cohérence et que N nous devons nous y
ranger
ensuite il suffit de converser avec l'un
quelconque des anciens secrétaires
généraux du Conseil constitutionnel pour
apprécier que il travaille intensément
sur les travaux
parlementaires et que pendant que nous
sommes
séance quelqu'un au Conseil
constitutionnel regarde ce que nous
disons à l'écoute et en tient
compte c'est d'ailleurs la seule chose
qui permet au Conseil constitutionnel de
pouvoir rendre ses décisions dans les
délais lu sont infér c'est qu'en réalité
une grande partie des sujets de droit
qu'il va avoir à traiter sont
préparés et enfin sur ce que nous
faisons
ici nous sommes
partiellement au moins co auteur de la
décision de
nomination l'autorité de nomination
doit respecter la décision que nous
prenons si plus de 25 d'entre nous
considère que la nomination n'est pas
légitime et donc nous sommes là pour
apprécier sur un ensemble de critères et
c'est l'objet de notre
discussion la légitimité compét d'une
proposition de nomination donc je crois
que c'est une mission utile que ça
concourt à l'équilibre des pouvoirs tout
simplement et donc nous nous n'avons pas
de raison d'être frustré de ce que nous
faisons
ici je
voudrais simplement dire que je crois
heureux à la différence de la nostalgie
du président du du reeur Géard je suis
heureux qu'il a une privatiste de
plus je suis heureux qu'il une
privatiste de plus au sein du Conseil
constitutionnel parce que le droit est
pluriel et parce que beaucoup de
décisions que le Conseil a à prendre
nécessite une connaissance intime du
droit pénal et du droit civil que non
pas tous les
publicistes
et je mais il peut arriver dans le casre
de l'élite de l'élite qu'un Conseil
d'État a quelques connaissance en droit
civil je ne fais pas partie de cette
élite malheureusement collèg vous êtes
tous ici des sénateurs ce qui a ce qui a
existé avant dans votre vie est très
important mais vous êtes fr absolument
je souhaite simplement sur la question
évoquée par Jean-Pierre Michel en
particulier sur les deux contrôles
rendre hommage l'observation qu'a faite
la présidente Maestra sur la vie de la
loi le Conseil en a fait la
théorie dans la décision sur la de CPC
sur la garde
vue en disant nous avons reconnu comme
en plus le Conseil avait été saisi je ne
sais combien de fois Jean-Pierre le sait
sûrement sur les la législation de la
garde à vue au cours des 20 dernières
années il avait parfois censuré parfois
déclaré conforme et donc il était amené
à dire ce que nous avons déclaré
conforme il y a 10 ans n'est plus
conforme et la la rédaction de cette
décision que je crois exemplaire répond
exactement à la définition enfin la à la
présentation que vous avez faite de la
l'évolution de la loi donc rendreage à
ça je simplement vous poser une question
à partir justement de
votre de vos multiples
fonctions on a fait une expérience avec
la loi sur le droit au logement
opposable c'est le dernier mot qui est
important on a
juridictionnalisé et rendu
essentiellement
procédural l'application d'un droit
social
ceci entraîne toute une série de
changements de
comportement notamment de la part de
l'administration de l'État dont
aujourd'hui la priorité principale est
d'éviter l'accumulation des
astreintes et de jouer un rôle de
prévention
financière et ça entraîne donc toute une
série de décisions en aval dont je
considère personnellement mais pour
l'instant je suis le seul de mon avis
qu'il dénature totalement les conditions
it logement et qu' modifie de façon
absolument incrôlé les quelques règles
de priorité les quelques critères sociau
d'attribution des logement qui PV
exister
auparavant à partir de cet
exemple vous demander votre appréciation
sur au fond est-ce qu' il serait
judicieux est-ce qu'il serait profitable
au règne du
droit que ces mesures puis ça envisagé
pour les places de crèche
quand quand un avocat est président de
la République ça ne peut pas ne pas
avoir de
conséquences que penseriez-vous d'une
extension de ces droits assortis d'un
pouvoir de mise en cause procédurale de
l'État merci Monsieur Richard monsieur
Portelli
oui madame je dois dire que je fais
partie de ce je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec le doyen Géard qui se
réjouissent de la présence des
magistrats en nombre au sein du Conseil
constitutionnel et notamment des
magistrats de l'ordre judiciaire pour
deux
raisons et c'est des c'est c'est mon
explication et en même temps une
question la première c'est que il y a un
lien étroit j'allais dire ombilical
depuis les origines entre le Conseil
d'État et le Conseil constitutionnel qui
tiennent à la fois à la façon dont se
fait le contrôle de constitutionnalité
au rôle du Conseil d'État dans en tant
que donneur d'avis sur les projets de de
loi et même des propositions de lois
aujourd'hui et je crois me rappeler que
ce n'est qu'à une seule reprise dans
l'histoire du Conseil constitutionnel
qu'un magistrat de l'ordre judiciaire a
été secrétaire général du Conseil
constitutionnel et donc il est pas
étonnant qu'il y ait ce ce tropisme et
le fait que les magistrats de l'ordre
judiciaire soient plus présents au sein
du Conseil me paraît une bonne chose
surtout que il me semble que bientôt on
va être amené non pas simplement à
changer et un certain nombre de membres
du Conseil constitutionnel mais
peut-être même aussi son secrétaire
général donc voilà la question que je
voulais vous poser c'est celle-là c'est
que traditionnellement il y a un lien
fort entre le Conseil d'État et le
Conseil constitutionnel par contre le
lien est plus tenu entre le Conseil
constitutionnel la Cour de cassation et
tout à l'heure on faisit allusion au CPC
et la façon dont la Cour de cassation a
transmis ou n'a pas à renvoyé plutôt n'a
pas renvoyé desqpc au au Conseil
constitutionnel
a pu parfois faire débat et notamment
quant à la possibilité de transmettre
des lois qu'elle avait déjà interprété
et dont elle estimait qu'elle les avait
bien interprété donc je voudrais avoir
un peu votre avis là-dessus savoir
est-ce que le la théorie du droit vivant
s'applique à toute la jurisprudence y
compris celle de la Cour de cassation la
deuxème question euh c'est justement la
conséquence de la première la présence
des magistrats me paraît importante
aussi pour une autre raison
euh le la défense des droits
fondamentaux aujourd'hui c'est encore
plus la défense des droits procéduraux
que des droits
matériels et personnellement je je me
réjouis de cette évolution qui va dans
le sens de ce que fait par exemple la la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
mais ça n'intéresse pas que la QPC ça
intéresse aussi la sisine parlementaire
et depuis maintenant en 2 ans le Conseil
constitutionnel est beaucoup plus
exigeant quant à la façon dont les
parlementaires motive leur saisine et
notamment il y a eu au moins une ou deux
décisions sur à l'occasion desquelles le
Conseil a pu donner son avis critique
sur la façon un peu désinvolte dont
certains parlementaires rédigaient
parfois leur saisine donc je voulais
savoir est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
une bonne chose est-ce que vous irez
dans ce sens à
l'avenir merci monsieur P je vis faire
une rectification depuis l'intervention
de Monsieur Portell de Monsieur Richard
je n'ai pas condamné la présence
majoritaire de magistrat j'ai simplement
fait un constat et je n'ai pas porté de
jugement sur le nombre de magistrats de
l'ordre judiciaire ou de l'ordre
administratif qui siégeait au Conseil
constitutionnel je tiens à le préciser
qu faiction sur voilà
uniquement j'ai pas dit que c'éitorable
jeai pas porté le jugement il y a
beaucoup de prof je tenais à le préciser
de professions qui ne sont pas
représentées n pas obligé d'être juriste
pour être enfin
bon il vaut mieux oui oui mais on peut
acquérir des oui oui
euh bon je je ne dis rien parce que je
préside monsieur Mercier merci merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Madame
madame la première présidente vous nous
avez indiqué à la fin de votre exposé
que
au début d'ailleurs que vous n'étiez pas
constitutionnaliste que vous étiez
simplement un magistrat de l' judiciaire
et que vous feriez tout pour acquérir
les compétences
nécessaires ne pensez-vous pas au
contraire que ces dernières années c'est
le Conseil constitutionnel qui a aidé ou
provoqué les évolutions majeures du
droit au moins du droit pénal si ce
n'est du droit civil également et que de
ce point de vue le droit pénal est
redevenu ce qu'il est vraiment
c'est-à-dire une branche du droit public
est très importante parce que c'est
l'action de l'État qui assure le vivre
ensemble à travers les sanctions que la
loi pénale prévoit mais au-delà de cette
remarque qui qui a pas grande importance
je voudrais vous poser une question à
travers un phénomène queon a pu Notter
sur la réforme de la garde à vue on a vu
une sorte de course entre les
juridictions et et vous le savez bien
Madame la première présidente entre la
Cour de Strasbourg entre la Cour de
cassation et entre le Conseil
constitutionnel et puis il faut bien
dire également avec le Parlement alors
on est arrivé à un résultat qui est
sûrement pas parfait notamment du point
de vue de la Cour de Strasbourg il y
aura sûrement des choses à revoir demain
dans ce droit-là mais je voudrais savoir
ce que vous pensez
de de ce concours entre guillemets des
juridictions et du Parlement pour
modifier un texte qui est quand même
fondamental et dans la vie quotidienne
malheureusement de de de beaucoup de
Français est arrivé à progresser avoir
un résultat on voit bien et que il y
avait à la fois de la part de la
juridiction de Strasbourg bah le désir
d'affirmer prééminence de la Cour de
cassation
de ne pas être dessaisi de ce qu'elle
considère comme étant son domaine et et
je dois dire
que l'affaire des QPC s'est plutôt
arrangé et quand on regarde les
dernières évolutions et que les
questions de personnes qui étaient
sous-jacentes à tout cela s'estompe un
peu faut bien dire la vérité et que ça
va plutôt mieux mais qu'on voit il y a
ce euh c'est une sorte de course entre
juridiction de de l'ordre international
de l'ordre interne du Conseil
constitutionnel du Parlement je voudais
que vous nous disiez comment vous voyez
les choses en tant que futur membre du
Conseil
constitutionnel bien merci Monsieur
Mercier je pense que le nombre de
questions est suffisant mes chers
collègues il n'y a pas de nouvelles
demande donc je vais demander à Madame
la première présidente Nicole maest rchi
de nous de vous apporter les réponses
qu'elle souhaitera vous apporter
merci
merci beaucoup alors je suis pas sûr de
pouvoir répondre complètement à toutes
les questions d'abord parce qu'il y a
des questions peut-être qui seront qui
auront l'occasion d'être examiné par le
Conseil constitutionnel par la suite et
que
donc même si je ne suis pas encore
définitivement désigné je m'astreins
quand même à une certaine réserve et
puis aussi parce que peut-être qu'il y a
des questions
auquels je ne peux pas répondre parce
que c'est des questions assez techniques
de droit constitutionnel alors
sur monsieur le sénateur Michel sur la
question
de du de l'étendue du contrôle à priori
qui ne se retrouve pas dans le contrôle
à postériori puisque lorsque le conseil
est saisi par une question prioritaire
de constitutionnalité il n'examine que
la question qui lui est posé alors que
quand il est sur contrôle à priori il
l'examine l'ensemble du texte et peut
relever euh des questions
d'inconstitutionnalité des cavaliers
effectivement qui est un sujet toujours
euh assez sensible euh qui euh n'aurait
pas dû euh qui ne ne se rapporte pas à
l'objet de la loi qui est examiné alors
bon euh sur cette question bon on
comprend assez bien l'objectif qui est
de faire en sorte que euh toutes les
questions soi euh fassent l'objet d'un
débat soit examiné et n'arrive pas euh
de manière
inopinée dans sur un texte euh alors que
ell n'ont pas été débattu maintenant il
me semble encore une fois sous réserve
de de ce que j'apprendrai par la suite
il me semble que euh le Conseil
constitutionnel fait quand même un usage
prudent de la possibilité qui lui est
donné
euh et que en tous les cas euh il a
toujours rappelé à l'occasion de
nombreux de nombreuses décisions que euh
il que le contrôle exercé par le le
Conseil constitutionnel était était
d'une nature différente de du travail
parlementaire et qu'en particulier euh
il n'était pas compétent pour apprécier
si les moyens euh mis en œuvre par le
Parlement étaient de nature
à réaliser les objectifs qui avaient été
fixés donc on sent bien que
effectivement on est toujours sur des
frontières assez floues et difficiles et
qu'en même
temps il m'a semblé à la lecture en
particulier des dernières décisions que
le Conseil avait fait un un usage assez
prudent et respectueux de ces
dispositions sur la question de euh
monsieur le sénateur Gard effectivement
j'ai eu l'occasion de voir dans d'autres
circonstances sur la question de d'une
majorité de de magistrats alors d'abord
notre Constitution contrairement à ce
qui se passe dans d'autres pays ne
prévoit aucune condition pour la
nomination des membres du Conseil
constitutionnel ni de conditions d'âge
ni de conditions de compétenence alors
que dans d'autres cours institutionnelle
il y a une exigence de compétenence
juridique alors est-il anormal je l'ai
dit en introduction il est vrai que la
QPC donne au Conseil
constitutionnel
indiscutablement une fonction
juridictionnelle un rôle de juridiction
est-ce qu'il est anormal qu'une
juridiction soit composée de
magistrat je je laisse cette question à
votre appréciation en tous les cas il me
semble que et pour répondre à d'autres
questions qui ont été posées le fait
d'avoir à la fois des privatistes des
publicistes et d'autres personnes issues
de la société civile me paraît important
contte tenu du développement du Conseil
constitutionnel je dirais et vous l'avez
rappelé
que les relations entre le Conseil
constitutionnel et le Conseil d'État ont
toujours été plus étroites d'ailleurs on
le voit dans les méthodes de travail qui
sont mises en œuvre au conse Conseil
constitutionnel qui se rapproche plus
des méthodes de travail du Conseil
d'État et il est vrai que la légitimité
de du juge judiciaire ou de lapport du
juge judiciaire c'est que le juge
judiciaire il voit tous les jours des
justiciables le juge judiciaire voit
tous les jours du justiciable et il sait
parce que quand on arrive à 25 ans juge
des enfants que les famille en crise
débarque dans votre bureau si vous
voulez la loi c'est un un cadre mais la
connaissance technique de la loi ne
suffit pas à trouver des
solutions
pragmatique juridique aux situations
qu'on est amené à trancher et je pense
que cet apport là c'est l'apport du juge
judiciaire donc voilà après il
m'appartient pas de porter une
appréciation sur la manière dont les
membres du Conseil constitutionnel sont
nommés en vertu de la Constitution
mais en tous les cas il ne me paraît pas
anormal que dès lors que le Conseil
constitutionnel évolue vers une cour
constitutionnelle et bien il y ait
peut-être plus de magistrats et de
magistrat qui est l'expérience des
fonction de juge c'est-à-dire de
trancher des litiges et qui est aussi
une expérience du délibéré parce qu'il
faut pas oublier que la fonction de juge
même si je regrette souvent
que de plus en plus les législateurs a
laissé la porte ouverte à des euh des
juridiction à juge unique c'est-à-dire
que le délibéré le la collégialité est
de moins en moins importante et de moins
en moins développé dans les juridictions
de l'ordre judiciaire néanmoins euh les
les juges judiciaires ont l'expérience
du délibéré
euh
monsieur le sénateur Gorse et bien
euh vous avez posé une question qui
n'était pas une question sur euh les les
conditions de nomination
de qui n'exigeait pas de réponse voilà
euh donc monsieur Béchu vous avez parlé
du du caractère imparfait de cette de
cette audition et vous m'avez posé
trois questions qui ne relèvent pas
véritablement du du champ du du du
Conseil constitutionnel vous m'avez
parler de mon expérience de chef de
juridiction et de de l'organisation de
de la carte judiciaire alors je
répondrai pas sur ce point parce que
c'est des questions qui peuvent sur
lesquelles on peut-être amené
à le le Conseil constitutionnel peut
peut-être amené à reprendre des
positions je dirais simplement que mon
expérience de chef de juridiction est et
en particulier j'ai été chef de
juridiction dans un département où il y
avait trois tribunaux de grande instance
la cénémarne je suis chef de cours
euh et la enne maritime il y a également
trois juridictions de première instance
euh c'est une
question enfin la
la la direction d'une d'une juridiction
dans ces conditions n'est pas
nécessairement chose facile dès lors que
il y a un seul préfet un seul président
de conseil général beaucoup de communes
et donc l'articulation entre tout ça
n'est pas simple en tous les cas
euh il me semble que la réflexion sur la
carte
judiciaire et sur l'organisation
judiciaire d'une manière générale
c'est-à-dire comment concilier proximité
du justiciable et sécurité juridique et
compétences des magistrats qui euh qui
prennent des décisions je crois que
cette on n'est pas arrivé au bout de la
réflexion ni les professionnel ni sans
doute le Parlement sur ces questions et
et voilà euh sur les questions qui
concerne dépénalisation
contrainventionnalisation alors là il
m'appartient pas de répondre je dirais
simplement
que la question du périmètre de la
justice pénale en tant que chef de
juridiction en tant que magistrat de
l'ordre judiciaire la seule chose que je
peux dire ici c'est que les juridictions
ne peuvent pas tout faire et bien faire
et que peut-être il faut se poser la
question de savoir ce qui doit être dans
le périmètre de la justice pénale et ce
qui doit être réglé par d'autres
instances ou qui doit faire l'objet
d'autres mode de régulation sociale je
me souviens du débat sur la
dépénalisation du chèque sans provision
il faut se souvenir que avec la
multiplication des checs sans provision
le Parlement avait eu plutôt tendance à
rendre plus sévères les disposition sur
le chèque sans provision et devant
l'échec de cette évolution euh la le
chèque sans provision a été dépénalisé
en 91 et la conséquence et d'autres
modes de régulation on été trouvé et la
conséquence n'a pas été que euh une un
affaiblissement de l'interdiction du
chèque sans provision me semble-t-il
donc voilà c'est une une réflexion plus
générale en tous les cas il appartiendra
au Parlement de se saisir de cette
question éventuellement sur le non
recours le le le non recours au droit et
l'effectivité des textes euh c'est vrai
que
euh la question de l'application de la
loi des lois est aussi importante que la
loi elle-même nous le savons les juges
judiciaires le le savent euh et la
question du non recours pose deux types
de questions elle pose une première
question sur la lisibilité de la loi et
une deuxième question forcément
sur est-ce que est-ce que une loi qui
n'est pas appliquée est-ce que c'est une
ou est-ce que c'est parce que on n' pas
prévu les conditions d'application
l'accompagnement nécessaire à
l'application de cette loi et on voit
bien l'articulation entre politique
publique et vote d'une loi est une
question qui n'est pas simple en tous
les cas je pense
que le juge constitutionnel a à
plusieurs repris
insister dans
ces dans les les objectifs qu'il a fixé
au au fil de ces décisions sur la
question de la clarté et de
l'accessibilité de la loi ces questions
seront de sans doute de plus en plus de
plus en plus au cœur des exence de nos
concitoyens donc voilà il y a une partie
certainement qui appartient au Parlement
il y a une partie qui appartient au
magistrat de l'ordre judiciaire et de
l'ordre administratif et il y a
peut-être une partie qui appartiendra au
Conseil
constitutionnel sur
le sur monsieur Quinta sur la question
de du
filtre de
la la complexité au fond de de la c'est
dur hein qui n'est pas forcément aussi
complexe dans d'autres pays européens
euh puisque aujourd'hui le juge du fond
transmet à la Cour de cassation qui
décide ou non à la Cour de cassation au
Conseil d'État qui décide ou non de
transmettre au Conseil constitutionnel
bon d'abord finalement si on regarde le
le le bilan aujourd'hui
sur les 1500 à peu près questions qui
ont été transmises au Conseil d'État et
à la Cour de cassation il y en a environ
300 qui ont été transmis au Conseil
constitutionnel
donc on a le sentiment que peut-être il
y a eu une régulation il est vrai que la
Cour de cassation a été certainement
plus réticente que le Conseil d'État au
départ il
a et et d'une part elle a
euh elle a voulu mettre en con urence la
la contrôle de conventionnalité et le
contrôle constitutionnel et d'autre part
elle a contesté au départ le fait que le
Conseil constitutionnel puisse euh
contrôler l'interprétation de la loi que
faisait la Cour de cassation aujourd'hui
il me semble qu'on en est plus là
puisque la Cour de cassation à plusieurs
reprises a dit a changé son
interprétation de la loi en disant
compte tenu de ma nouvelle
interprétation de cette loi et bien il
n'est plus
euh le la saisine du Conseil
constitutionnel n'a plus d'objet voilà
donc si vous voulez il me semble mais
c'est toujours un équilibre fragile on a
un système qui est assez complexe et qui
est pas forcément toujours extrêmement
lisible certainement pour le justiciable
moyen on a un système assez complexe qui
est on a beaucoup parlé de dialogue des
juges le dialogue des juges ça se passe
toujours à un niveau qui est euh pas
forcément euh euh toujours extrêmement
compréhensible mais en tous les cas ce
dialogue des juges il semble avoir eu
lieu parce que euh aujourd'hui le nombre
des euh questions qui qui le nombre de
questions transmises paraît assez
euh satisfaisant par rapport au nombre
de questions qui ont été transmises à la
Cour de cassation et au Conseil d'État
euh alors sur
le monsieur Colomba sur le fait de
savoir si le rôle du Conseil
constitutionnel doit être franchement
politique vous comprendrez bien que je
ne peux pas vous répondre sur cette
question en tous les cas le rôle du
Conseil constitutionnel c'est de
contrôler la constitutionnalité de la
loi ça c'est peut-être une réponse un
peu langue de bois mais néanmoins il est
évident que comme n'importe quelle
juridiction en contrôlant la la la
conformité d'un d'un texte
au
principes au principes généraux du droit
aux libertés fondamentales et bien
évidemment le Conseil constitutionnel
fait une interprétation il tient compte
de ce qui se du contexte il ce qui
compte de ce qui se passe il est pas
dans une tour d'ivoire entièrement coupé
de tout alors après c'est pas à au
Conseil constitutionnel qu'il appartient
d'établir les priorités les priorités
c'est le gouvernement et c'est le
législateur et le Conseil
constitutionnel il a un rôle important
parce que il a nécessairement un rôle
d'interprétation mais il a un rôle
limité parce qu'il se borne simplement
à vérifier si
euh les textes sont conformes aux droits
et libertés garantis par la Constitution
et c'est déjà un rôle suffisamment
important
euh monsieur le sénateur leer vous nous
avez vous m'avez posé la question de la
méthode et vous vous êtes interrogé sur
la manière dont le Conseil
constitutionnel pouvait censurer les
lois sans toujours sans avoir parfois
peut-être tous les éléments sur
l'intention du législateur mais le
monsieur le sénateur Richard vous aait
indiqué que effectivement le Conseil
constitutionnel se tenait manifestement
au courant en temps réel de l'évolution
du débat parlementaire et que donc il
n'ignorait pas les intentions du
législateur faut-il ou non prévoir
d'auditionner les rapporteurs c'est une
question sur laquelle je ne répondrai
pas mais c'est une question que je
trouve en tous les cas intéressante et
il me semble que le Conseil
constitutionnel à plusieurs reprises a
pu
entendre par exemple je pense à la loi
modernisation sociale où il a entendu
d'utres acteurs comme les organisations
syndicales salariés et et patronnal où
il me semble ce qui démontre que le
Conseil constitutionnel n'est pas dans
un tour d'ivoir complètement coupé de la
réalité
euh alors est-ce que le le Conseil
constitutionnel doit être continuer à
être un outil de
rationalisation du travail parlementaire
euh c'est la Constitution qu'il prévoit
d'une certaine manière hein alors
jusqu'où doit-il aller voilà ce que je
disais tout à l'heure sur les cavaliers
il me semble que les décisions qui ont
été
prises montrent que le Conseil
constitutionnel exerce un un contrôle
déterminant mais néanmoins très prudent
sur pour ne pas empiéter justement sur
les pouvoirs du Parlement
euh
euh alors Monsieur euh le sénateur
Richard
euh vous nous avez oui vous nous avez
vous vous m'avez posé la question de
euh
de de texte de de l'application de texte
comme euh la loi d'Alo qui effectivement
euh
entraînit en amont de son application un
certain nombre de changements de
comportement des acteurs alors d'abord
la loi d'Allo euh là aussi je serais
assez prudente sur l'interprétation
parce que il n'est pas absolument
évident qu'elle ne revienneent pas d'une
manière ou d'une autre devant vous et
donc devant le Conseil constitutionnel
la loi d'allau c'est la c'est la
première fois qu'une loi se disait
opposable et je me souviens bien des
débats on a dit mais enfin comment
voulez-vous appeler une parce que euh la
loi d'Allo c'était une loi qui était
beaucoup portée par les associations et
en particulier par la Fédération que je
présidais aussi et on disait mais une
loi une loi opposable c'est un pléonasme
puisque par définition toutes les lois
sont opposables je dirais que néanmoins
une loi qui prévoyait des sanctions même
si on pourrait discuter sur le les
limites de cette loi une loi qui
comporter des sanctions certes elle peut
avoir des effets un peu négatifs mais
aussi elle a eu des effets positifs
c'est-à-dire que euh
elle a obligé alors on peut s'interroger
sur les raisons pour lesquelles euh il a
fallu attendre une loi pour y obligé
mais elle a obligé les acteurs locaux à
avoir un dialogue sur l'attribution des
logements sur euh le l'accessibilité au
logement d'un certain nombre de
personnes et mais elle a mis autour de
la table des gens qui n'y étaient pas et
donc dans la plupart des cas la loi
d'Allo a eu un effet très positif après
une loi comme vous l'avez rappelé
vous-même elle ne pie pas
euh
le le manque de logement sur un
territoire donné et ça a été
particulièrement le cas sur la région
parisienne où effectivement son
application a été nécessairement à
rencontrer beaucoup de limites alors sur
le les méthodes monsieur Portelli sur
les méthodes de travail du Conseil
d'État et de la Cour de cassation Mo je
crois avoir répondu et sur
l'interprétation sur la possibilité pour
la le Conseil constitutionnel de porter
un regard sur la manière dont une loi
est interprétée
euh et
euh
monsieur le sénateur Mercier monsieur le
ministre
euh vous avez insisté
sur le fait que le Conseil
constitutionnel avait joué un rôle
important dans le pour l'évolution du
droit privé en particulier du droit
pénal à propos de la réforme de la garde
à vue et vous avez parlé de cette
concurrence qui s'est euh installée
effectivement
entre la le Conseil constitutionnel la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme et
la cour de cassation avec la difficulté
que vous connaissez qui est le Conseil
constitutionnel qui a rendu une décision
avec un effet euh retardé dans le temps
pour laisser au Parlement le soin de
prendre un nouveau texte avec une dans
une situation qui pour les praticiens
que j'étais à l'époque n'était pas
extrêmement confortable la Cour de
cassation qui commence à dire et bien on
va appliquer le même délai qui en
assemblée plainère dit mais attendez la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme et
bien si on a une décision qui est
contraire à la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme et bien un texte qui
est contraire à à la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme il faut
l'abroger immédiatement donc il faut ne
pas l'appliquer immédiatement et donc on
s'est trouvé quand même dans une
situation très rapidement assez
inconfortable donc effectivement le
délai le délai de de cet interstice
juridique vide nous a posé un certain
nombre de questions alors c'est vrai que
c'est ce qui conduit un certain nombre
de professeurs de droit constitutionnel
à dire que il faudrait peut-être que le
Conseil constitutionnel a est plus loin
dans le contrôle de la conventionnalité
des textes ça c'est une question sur
laquelle je ne me prononcerai pas vous
l'imaginez bien euh j'espère avoir
répondu à toutes les questions voilà
hein et je vous remercie de m'avoir
écouté c'est nous c'est nous qui qui
vous remercions
voilà pour ces auditions je vous
rappelle que la nomination de Nicole
maestraci a été approuvée au Sénat par
17 voix pour 6 contes et de bulletins
blanc quant à Nicole Boubé sa nomination
a été approuvée par 13 voix contre 11 et
un bulletin blanc voilà pour donc ces
auditions merci à vous de les avoir
suivis prochain rendez-vous avec
l'actualité parlementaire c'est cet
après-midi à partir de 16h30 vous
pourrez suivre les travaux de la
commission des lois sur le mariage pour
tous bonne journée à
tous